OKAY. ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY WE ARE HERE FOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
RESTARTING THE ARMS FOR BEST
PRACTICES FOR SAFELY RE OPENING
WE ARE THE COMMITTEE OF ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM
AND INTERNET MEDIA. AND WE HAVE
A JAM PACKED AGENDA TODAY AND
WE ARE VERY EXCITED FOR ALL OF
THE PROFESSIONALS AND EXPERTS
IN THIS AREA TO JOIN US. I'M
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA AND WE WELCOME YOU HERE
WE ALSO WELCOME OUR NEW VICE
CHAIR SUZETTE WELL THERE IS AND
SHE WILL BE MAKING SOME BRIEF
REMARKS. AND OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBER DR STEVEN CHOI I SEE OUT
THERE. UP BEFORE WE BEGAN WE
HAVE SOME HOUSEKEEPING AND WE
WILL BE PRACTICING NOT ONLY
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THEME. IN
THIS HEARING BUT ALSO
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CAPITOL.
WE HAVE VERY LIMITED SPACE SO
OUR SPEAKERS WILL BE COMING TO
YOU REMOTELY- WE ENCOURAGE
THOSE THAT ARE WATCHING. THAT
THEY CAN GO ON TO THE ASSEMBLY
WEBPAGE TOCALL. IN DURING THE
PUBLIC COMMENT SEGMENT OF THIS
HEARING- THE NUMBER TO CALL CAN
BE FOUND ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. OR ON THE SCREEN LATER
ON DURING THIS HEARING- THIS IS
THE SECOND IN A SERIES OF
HEARINGS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WILL HOLD ON THE IMPACT OF KOBE
NINETEEN. AND ON THE PEOPLE AND
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA'S ARTS
TOURISM AND SPORTS INDUSTRIES.
WE HELD AND FIRST INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IN OCTOBER AND THAT WAS
ON THE ECONOMIC POWER AND
RESILIENCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
TOURISM INDUSTRY WHERE THE
COMMITTEE NOT ONLY. LEARNED
FIRSTHAND FROM SOME OF THE- OR
THOSE WHO PROVIDE TOURISM AND
ENTERTAINMENT OF THE
DIFFICULTIES AND CHALLENGES
THEY FACE AND WE KNOW THAT THAT
HAS BEEN DEEP. AND UNWAVERING
AND THIS PANDEMIC- WE ALSO WERE
ABLE TO BRING TO YOU ARRAY OF
INTEREST ROUPS TO WORK WITH
THAT WORK WITHIN THE TOURIST
INDUSTRY AND THIS HEARING
BROUGHT PERSPECTIVES ON THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND WILDFIRES. AS WELL
AS THE PROPOSALS FOR HELP
CALIFORNIA'S TOURISM INDUSTRY
CAN RECOVER. NOW ALMOST FOUR
MONTHS LATER WE ARE GOING TO BE
FOCUSING ON OUR ARTISTS AND
THOSE WHO WORK WITH THEM AS WE
KNOW THE ARTS CULTURE AND
CREATIVE ECONOMY SECTORS HAVE
BEEN AMONG THE HARDEST HIT BY
THIS CORONAS. CORONA VIRUS AND
PANDEMIC WE ALSO KNOW THAT ARTS
AND TAMAR KINNER CAME IN ARE
ALSO SOME OF THE MOST
THERAPEUTIC WAYS THAT PEOPLE
CAN HELP HELP AND BEGIN TO
RECOVER SAID TODAY WE WILL BE
HEARING FROM A FORM OF FROM
MUSEUMS AND GALLERIES
PERFORMANCE VENUES TO SHARE
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THEIR
EXPERIENCES WITH THE POPE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ESPECIALLY IN
THE PAST THE IMPACT OF STAY AT
HOME ORDERS. ON THEIR
BUSINESSES AND STAFF AND OF
COURSE FROM THE ARTISTS
THEMSELVES WE WANT YOU TO KNOW
THE EFFORTS THAT THE GOVERNMENT
HAS BEEN MAKING SO FAR AND WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- IS
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE
ASKING FOR GREATER ASSISTANCE.
BEST PRACTICES FOR YOU RE
OPENING FROM YOU THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE IN THE INDUSTRY AND HOW
TO BEST REOPEN EITHER NOT ONLY
FROM EXAMPLES FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES FROM US BUT FROM
OTHER STATES. AND ALSO LOOKING
AGAIN AT OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
ORDERS THAT HAVE COME DOWN FROM
OUR DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. YOUR
EXPERIENCES WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL FOR MEMBERS TO HEAR AS
WE MOVE INTO OUR SECOND
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. UNDER THIS
PANDEMIC. AS YOU CAN SEE THE
AGENDA IS JAM PACKED VERY
ROBUST- WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
WE COULD GET AS MANY VOICES
AGAIN THAT BEING SAID- WE NEED
TO STICK TO THE AGENDA AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE WILL BE ASKING
MEMBERS TO MAKE THEIR COMMENTS-
THREE. AND AFTER OUR FIRST
PANEL SPEAKS WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE WITNESSES
THAT YOU STAY ON TIME WE
APPRECIATE SO MUCH JOIN US BUT
WE WANT YOU TO. BE AWARE OF
YOUR TIME AND- AGAIN WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD AND I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE OUR NEWS
VICE CHAIR- THAT FALL THERE IS
TO MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM FOR
WOMEN AND I AM EXCITED TO. BE
HERE AND MY VERY YEAH COMMITTEE
HEARING MEETING WITH YOU AND
REALLY AT A CRITICAL TIME- FOR
THE CENTERS FOR THE ARTS
INDUSTRY AND THE THIRTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ON BIG AND
SMALL WHETHER IT'S A REGULAR
LIBRARY SIX FLAGS MAGIC
MOUNTAIN. OR CANYON THEATRE
GUILD ON THIS INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
HIT PARTICULARLY HARD AND I'M
EXCITED TO. HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT RESTARTING
THE ARTS AND TO REALLY LOOK AT
ON THE SUSTAINABILITY AND HOW
WE NOT ONLY OPEN THAT WE COME
BACK STRONGER THAN EVER AND I'M
EXCITED TO HEAR EVERYONE'S
IDEAS THOUGHTS AND TO BE A PART
OF THE CONVERSATION. THANK YOU.
AND I DO SEE IS THAT OR- YES
SENATOR BEN ALLEN HAS JOINED
US- AND AS HE JOINED AS WE
DEFINITELY LEFT TO HAVE HIM
MAKE SOME OPENING REMARKS
SENATOR. FOR HER- GREAT TO BE
HERE OBVIOUSLY I HAD WANTED
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR WHO
ALSO SERVES AS VICE CHAIR TO
THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON THE ARTS
WHICH IS OUR- JOINT LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE THAT LOOKS A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES. AND I KNOW THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF OUR TWENTY MANY
MEMBERS WHO ARE ARE FOLLOWING
THE MEETING REMOTELY- VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC SOMETHING THAT
ARE COMMITTEES BEEN LOOKING AT
AS WELL INSIDE JUST HAPPY TO BE
HERE AND- WE- YOU KNOW WE JUST
KNOW HOW MUCH. ARE FRIENDS OF
THE ARTS COMMUNITY THAT'S
SUFFERING. I'VE GOT TO FIGRE
OUT WAYS TO ALLOW THEM TO GET
BACK ONLINE IN A SAFE WAY BUT
THAT ALSO ALLOWS THEM TO.
CONTINUE TO- TO DO THEIR WORK
SO. REALLY REALLY I'M IMPRESSED
WITH THE WITH THE WITH THE
FOLKS WHO WHO ARE ON THIS. LIST
I WANT TO THANK THE STAFF
INCLUDING- OUR OWN JOY
COMMITTEE STAFFER HELPING TO
PUT THIS TOGETHER. I LEARNED
HAS REMAINS AND- LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION. YES AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE BEING. VICE CHAIR OF
THE ARTS COUNCIL AND- LOOK
FORWARD WHEN WE BOTH CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO GET OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY- WHERE ARE OUR WHOLE
GOAL HERE IS TO GET THESE
VENUES OPEN SAFELY. AND THAT WE
CAN GET OUT AND ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE ARTS
TOGETHER- THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
NOAH. COMING ACROSS THE WAY
OVER HERE TO THE GREENHOUSES-
WE APPRECIATE IT FOR FIFTY FIVE
EARNED YOU TO MATCH THAT MUCH
BIGGER ROOM YEAH. AND AGAIN I'M
ALREADY BREAKING THE TIME BUT
I'LL JUST DO IT BECAUSE I KNOW
OUR MEMBERS GOT HERE ON TIME.
AND THEY WILL BE IN AND OUT BUT
LET ME- DR STEVEN CHOI IDEA OF
ANY OPENING COMMENTS BEFORE WE
JUMP IN. THANK YOU FOR ASKING
ME. I OF I AM SO HAPPY TO MEET
UP WITH THE- NEW MAKE UP OF
COMMITTEE I SERVED UP FROM THE-
PRIOR SESSION ON THIS
COMMITTEE- I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE- IS- PROBABLY-
RESPONSE FOR OF FOUR- WIDER
SPECTRUM OF- INDUSTRY THAN ANY
OF THE- COMMITTEES SO IT
INCLUDES ALL ARTS.
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AN
INTERNET MEDIA THERE IS- WHO
CAN TALK ABOUT- DECISIONS ALL
DAY LONG AND THAT THIS ALSO ARE
IMPORTANT AS- A GERMAN NOW
AGAIN NICE IS- SPECIFIC- ITEM
SO AS WE MEET OUR BE HAPPY TO-
PARTICIPATE THAT BECAUSE OF THE
ERA OF MANY ISSUES SET UP-
CURRENTLY WE ARE FACING BECAUSE
OF ALL OF THE NINETEEN
SITUATION SUCH AS A SPORTS. AND
ALSO REASON- DRAMA THAT THE WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE- SOCIAL MEDIA
WITH THE- FREEDOM OF SPEECH
ISSUE- HOW I AM REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT AT ALL WHAT HAS
HAPPENED AND WE HAVE WITNESSED
ACT- ABRIDGING OUR FREEDOM OF
SPEECH. UNDER THE NAME OF OUR-
PRIVATE COME. IT SAYS SO MANY
THINGS HAVE HAPPENED CAN TALK.
BUT ANY MAY OUR LAW JUST A
LESSON AND A CITY HOW TODAY'S A
PRESENTER SOMEONE. MAKE US A
BETTER INFO THE- COMMITTEE MAY.
THANK DR CHOI AND- SOMEONE FREE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIRST I
WANTED CONGRATULATE THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR- LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU BOTH- LIKE
MANY PEOPLE IN LOSS AND IN
CALIFORNIA I MOVED TO LOS
ANGELES I HAVE TO ACCEPT A JOB
IN THE FILM INDUSTRY PARAMOUNT
PICTURES AFTER WORKING IN NEW
YORK FOR HBO AND OTHER
COMPANIES- MOST OF MY A LOT OF
MY CONSTITUENTS EITHER WORK IN
ENTERTAINMENT OR IN INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE TANGENTIALLY RELATED
TO ENTERTAINMENT AND
HOSPITALITY AND REPRESENTS HOW
HE WOULD. A FIVE FILM STUDIOS
IN MY DISTRICT AND- HAVE A
LONG- YOU KNOW HISTORY IN THE
INDUSTRY YEAH AS WELL AS HAVING
A LOT OF LIVE VENUES. LATER IN
THE ALEX THEATRE IN THE OTHERS.
AND THIS IS THE STORY ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA- TOURISM
ENTERTAINMENT IS REALLY.
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR IDENTITY AS
CALIFORNIANS. SO GIVING
GUIDANCE TO THIS INDUSTRY
GIVING THEM CLEAR BENCHMARKS
CLEAR ROAD MAP TO FOLLOW. IS
CRUCIAL. FOR THE ACCOUNT OUR
ENTIRE ECONOMY AND OUR IDENTITY
AS CALIFORNIA BECAUSE LOSING
THOSE INDUSTRIES WILL BE A HUGE
BLOW. TO WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
SO SPECIAL- OUR CREATIVE
ECONOMY WHICH- ALSO HELPS FUEL
SILICON VALLEY AND ALL THINGS
THAT OUR INTELLECTUAL CAPITAL.
SO I WANT TO COMMEND THE CHAIR
FOR. SETTING UP THIS HEARING-
REALLY REALLY ARE GRATEFUL FOR
YOU FOR DOING THAT AND I LOOK
FORWARD PARTICIPATING TODAY
THANKS. THANK YOU AND THEN I
DID SEE ONE OF OUR- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THIS AREA. DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR THAT AFTER
THIS KEEP VERY CLOSE TO THE
AGENDA. OKAY WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND START WITH OUR FIRST
CHAIR. OR MEDICARE IT'S DAVID
CHIU- HELLO I JUST. THAT'S OKAY
YOU MIGHT OF AVENGERS YES OF
COURSE I DIDN'T SEE YOU THERE
OKAY WELL WORRISOME REMEMBER.
THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING FIRST
OF ALL MANAGER REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR CONVENE SUCH A GREAT
PANEL ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION- AN EARLIER PART
OF MY LIFE I WAS AN AMATEUR
MUSICIAN AND- AND THAT IT WAS
THROUGH THAT BUT I MADE SOME
SPENDING THINKING THAT THROUGH
SCHOOL AND- TODAY REPRESENT A
CITY- CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
THAT IS AN ARTISTIC CAPITAL NOT
ONLY FOR THE BAY AREA BUT FOR
OUR STATE- OUR CITY. HAS NOT
ONLY VERY LARGE INTERNATIONALLY
KNOWN INSTITUTIONS BUT SMALLER
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
IN A VERY VIBRANT BUT
STRUGGLING ARTS COMMUNITY. AND
I CAN CERTAINLY SPEAK AS OTHERS
HAVE FOR OUR CITY IN A REGION
THAT THE ARTS ARE NOT ONLY A
REFLECTION OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
OUR VISION FOR THE WORLD BUT AN
ENORMOUS ECONOMIC DRIVER JOBS
DRIVER TOURISM DRIVER. AND SO
THIS IS INCREDIBLY TIMELY AND I
WANT TO JUST NOTE THAT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THE FOR CODED ARTS
FUNDING AND SUPPORT WAS
SOMETHING I DON'T THINK OUR
STATE HAD PRIOR TIES IN THE WAY
THAT IT SHOULD I THINK THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN DO MORE AND
SHOULD DO MORE. BUT CERTAINLY
DURING COVERT WITH SO MANY DARK
CRISES IT HAS AGAIN BEEN HARD
TO PRIORITIZE THE ARTS AND WE
ARE AT RISK OF LOSING MANY
IMPORTANT INSTITUTIONS AND
ARTISTS SO I JUST WANTED TO SAY
JUST HOW HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE
ENGAGEMENT TODAY- AND- AND LOOK
FOR THE CONVERSATION WILL BE
TAKING LOTS OF NOTES
UNFORTUNATELY TOGGLING BETWEEN
A COUPLE OF MEETINGS BUT- REST
ASSURED MY STAFF AND I ARE
TRACKING THIS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH- WITH.
OUR CHAIR AND ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND OTHERS TO ADVANCE
THE CAUSE OF THE ARTS- IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER Q. AND- I'D
LIKE. YOU PROPPING UP WHERE ALL
THE MEDIAN DIFFERENT ANGLES SO
THERE WE HAVE A SOME- FROM ALL
BLURRED WHO WILL BE SAYING FROM
AN INFILL COMMENTS VERY GO YEAH
THANK YOU MADAM I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALSO FOR CONVENING THIS
HEARING- IT'S ONE OF MY MOST-
FAVORITE COMMITTEES BECAUSE I'M
SO PASSIONATE ABOUT THE ARTS
AND ICE I CERTAINLY BELIEVE
THAT IF THERE IS ANY SECTOR OUT
THERE THAT CAN SAVE US- IT IS
THE ARTS COMMUNITY. N. ECHOING
THE SENTIMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES- FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO YOU KNOW THE ARTS
HAVE BEEN WOEFULLY UNDERFUNDED-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE HAVE REALLY ASK. OUR ARTS
COMMUNITY- TO FIND WAYS TO SAVE
US ALL INFORM THEMSELVES AND I
THINK DURING THIS TIME OF
COPAYS WHEN WE HAVE ACTUALLY
RELYING ON HARD. TO HELP US
TRANSLATE INFORMATION HE'LL
FOCUS- MAKE FOLKS FEEL SAFE-
DISTRACT FOLKS FROM OTHER
THINGS THAT THEY'RE HEARING ON
THE NEWS OR THEIR OWN ANXIETIES
IT SHOULD BE A REMINDER TO THE
STATE. THAT WE MUST DEEPLY FUND
AND SUPPORT OUR ARTISTS SO I'M-
VERY INTERESTED IN HEARING-
FROM OUR SPEAKERS TODAY IT IS A
JAM PACKED HARING I'M
ESPECIALLY CURIOUS TO KNOW HOW
ARE SMALLER VENUES HAVE BEEN
SURVIVING AND WHAT THEY NEED
FROM US NINETY NINE SEAT
THEATERS- OUTDOOR PARKING USED.
YOU KNOW HOW MUSEUMS BUT ALSO
GALLERIES WHAT KIND OF SUPPORT
THEY NEED- TO SAFELY REOPEN IT
TO STAY OPEN AND THEN AT SOME
POINT YOU KNOW I WOULD ACTUALLY
BE I'M VERY INTERESTED IN.
ARTISTS WHO WRITE BECAUSE SINCE
WE HAVE HAD TO TRANSITION FROM
A LIVE AND IN PERSON
ACTIVITIES- WHERE THERE SEEMS
TO BE A VERY CLEAR DELINEATION
BETWEEN ART AND- SORT OF.
OPERATOR NOW THAT WE'RE
STREAMING AND SHARING
INFORMATION USING TECHNOLOGY I
WOULD LOVE FOR US TO AT SOME
POINT HAVE A DEEPER DISCUSSION
ABOUT- ARTIST WRITES IN SORT OF
WHO OWNS WHAT IS BEING SHARED
SINCE WE'RE USING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES. IT MIGHT SEEM A
LITTLE AMBIGUOUS BUT I KNOW FOR
OUR FOR ACTORS AND MUSICIANS
WHO ARE USED TO CREATING THEIR
OWN WORK AND THEN SHARING IT ON
THE STAGE- THIS THIS THESE NEW
DEVICES COULD COMPLICATE SOME
OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS BUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CONVENING THIS
AND I. AM VERY. EXCITED TO HEAR
WHAT FOLKS HAVE TO SAY. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY COM YOUR GOOD. AND
IF- OF THE PANELISTS HAVE HEARD
THAT INITIAL COMMENTS ON IT AND-
THE CONCERNS BY THE MEMBERS IT
WOULD BE GREAT IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THOSE IN YOUR COMMENTS.
THAT BEING SAID WE'RE GOING TO
START OUR FIRST PANEL WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA AND- THE ARTS
CHALLENGES AND PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT THE ARTS. WE HAVE. FIVE
PANELISTS ON THIS WHAT WE'LL DO
IS GO STRAIGHT UP FROM ONE
PANELIST AND THEN THE OTHER
WITHOUT ANY QUESTIONS IN
BETWEEN. AGAIN WE ASK OUR
PANELISTS TO STAY ON TIME OUR
FIRST PRESENTER IS ADAM. FOX
FALL OVER FROM THE DIRECTOR OF
RESEARCH BECAUSE- HE CAN
ECONOMIES IN CALIFORNIA
CREATIVE KANEMI WELCOME ADAM.
GOOD MORNING. YES WE HEAR YOU
THANK YOU HOPEFULLY YOU CAN SEE
MY SLIDES AS WELL. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE LIVE BUT WE DON'T
SEE YOU UNLESS YOU'RE OKAY.
THAT'S HOW IT'S GOING TO BE YES
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
CHAIR- I'M HERE TODAY IN MY
FIVE MINUTES TO TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE WORK OUR FIRM BEACON
ECONOMICS HAS BEEN DOING FOR
THE UPCOMING TWENTY TWENTY ONE
OTIS CREATIVE ECONOMY REPORT
THAT WILL BE RELEASED LATER
THIS MONTH- I'D LIKE TO SHARE
SOME OF OUR RESEARCH FROM OVER
THE PAST SIX MONTHS. SOME OF
THE QUANTITATIVE AS WELL AS
QUALITATIVE FINDINGS- WE'VE
BEEN SAYING AS WE LOOKED AT THE
ECONOMIC DATA THE DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA AND TALK TO STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS THE ECOSYSTEM- ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY I ALWAYS LIKE TO REMIND
FOLKS IN FOR SEAN IS PART OF
THE ECONOMY SO OFTEN TIMES.
SINCE ABOUT THE ARTS ARE OFTEN.
AS OTHER AS A NICE- AS A NICE
OPTION TO HAVE EVERYTHING ELSE
IS TAKEN CARE OF. I'D LIKE TO
PUSH BACK TODAY A LITTLE BIT
AGAINST THAT NOTION. WE SEE THE
ARTS AS A VIBRANT PART VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY- TALKING ABOUT THE
LARGER LABOR MARKET SINCE THE
DEPTHS OF THE DOWNTURN IN
APRIL. WE'VE ONLY RECOVERED 44%
OF OUR JOBS CALIFORNIA IN
DECEMBER THERE WERE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION FEWER PEOPLE
EMPLOYED IN THE STATE THEN IN
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY. OR NON
FARM EMPLOYMENT HAS CONTRACTED
ROUGHLY 8% SINCE FEBRUARY THIS
BASIC GROWTH THIS RECOVERY
TRAILS IN THE NATION OVERALL
WHERE THE NUMBER OF JOBS IS.
ONLY SHRUNK BY SIX POINT 5% IT
IT. NINETEEN POSES SIGNIFICANT
LOSSES TO THE CREATIVE ECONOMY
AND FOR RURAL PARTS OF THE
STATE. ARTS CULTURE CREATIVITY
THESE ARE SOME OF THE KEY
SECTORS THAT DRIVE OUR REGIONAL
ECONOMIES THERE SO VERY
IMPORTANT WHEN WE LOOK AT
ECONOMIC DRIVERS IN OUR RURAL
AREAS. BY THEIR VERY NATURE
MANY OF THE CONSTITUENT PARTS
OF THE CREATIVE ECONOMY
NECESSITATE THE CONGREGATION OF
A LARGE GROUPS OF UNRELATED
PEOPLE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THE
SAME ALSO OFTEN IN VERY CLOSE
PROXIMITY GIVEN THE NATURE. OF
OUR REAL ESTATE MARKETS IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU HAVE TO USE
SPACE CREATIVELY. WHEN THE
VENUE IS A SMALL LOCAL ARE A
LARGE OUTDOOR CONCERT VENUE AND
ARTS MUSEUM THESE WERE THE
FIRST INDUSTRIES WE SAW TAKE A
HIT. AND WE EXPECT THEM TO BE
THE LAST ONE TO MAKE A FULL
RECOVERY I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT THE FIRST OUT IN THE
LAST BACK- IN OUR REPORT WE
BREAK THESE DOWN ITO FIVE KIND
OF GLOBAL INDUSTRY SECTORS. AS
SEATING ON THE SCREEN- AT THE
END OF THE MONTH WILL BE
RELEASING- THE ELDEST REPORT
WHICH WILL CAPTURE ALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY WITH THE SPECIAL
CHAPTER. ON THE CALL WITH
NINETEEN M. PACT- IT'S GONNA BE
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT REPORT
THIS YEAR BY IN THE FALL WHEN
WE WERE BEGAN OUR ANALYSIS- I.
DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
NUMBERS THESE WILL BE UPDATED
AS I MENTIONED IN THE END OF
THE MONTH- BUT FOR NOW I THINK
THEY GIVE A GOOD INDICATION. AS
THERE'S BEEN VERY LITTLE
RECOVERY- GOING INTO NOVEMBER
DECEMBER- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE CULTURAL INDUSTRIES- WE
CLING FILM ADVERTISING DIGITAL
DIGITAL VISUAL ARTS. AS WELL AS
THOSE OCCUPATIONS THAT MAY BE
HOUSED IN NON CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES- PERFORMERS
ARCHITECTS GRAPHIC DESIGNERS
THAT MAY WORK AT FIRMS THAT ARE
INTEGRATED INDUSTRY. THEY COME
FROM THE SAME WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE THE SAME
ECOSYSTEM OF NONPROFIT
PARTICIPANTS EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES. IN ADDITION- TO THE
DIRECT CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
ARTS AND CULTURAL SECTOR
SUPPORTS A LARGE NUMBER OF
OTHER PROFESSIONS BOTH UPSTREAM
AND DOWNSTREAM. AS YOU SEE
HERE- IN THE FALL IN AUGUST WE
ESTIMATED ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND- JOBS- LOST
MISSING TEMPORARILY FURLOUGHED-
IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS A- HAS A
HUGE IMPACT FOR THOSE SUPPLIERS
UP CHANGE UP. THE FOOD CHAIN OF
THE- SUPPLY CHAIN AND FOR THOSE
PHONES THAT USE THAT WAGE
INCOME TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
LOCAL ECONOMY. THERE'S SOME
INHERENT STRUCTURAL OCCUPATIONS
THAT MAKE- ARTS WORKERS
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
THESE UNDERLYING CHANGES. ONE
OF THE MAIN NOTES IS THAT.
FOLKS ARE THREE AND A HALF
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE SELF
EMPLOYED IN THE ARTS WE HAVE TO
LEVERAGE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
DATA SOURCES AND THINKING WE
BECAUSE OF THE CARE ACT THE
PANDEMIC OUT OF ONE OF THE
SYSTEMS PROGRAM. AND ALLOW
THOSE FOLKS TO CONTINUE TO-
EXHIBIT NORMAL HOUSEHOLD
SPENDING BEHAVIOR. AS I COME UP
ON MY TIME AND SAY NO WHERE HAS
THE IMPACT BEEN TO WRITE AND
MORE IMMEDIATE. IN PERFORM ARTS
AND WE'VE SEEN A NAY WHY- THERE
IN TAX EXEMPT REVENUE- IN IN
THE THIRD QUARTER OF ROUGHLY
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT. THIS IS
DEVASTATING. AS WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WHAT RECOVERY LOOKS LIKE IN
THE STATE. IT IS OUR
RECOMMENDATION THAT ANY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT RECOVERY
ANY RESILIENCE NARRATIVE
INCLUDE THE ARTS THERE ARE SUCH
A VALUABLE- IMPORTANT PLAYER
AND THERE'S A LOT THAT CAN BE
DONE. A LOT OF OUR LOCAL
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR THE REBOUND OF THE
ARTS IN THE WAYS THAT THE
INDUSTRIES ARE CHANGING. WE
HAVE A LOT OF CONTROL OVER HOW
WE CURATE OUR ECONOMIC
REGULATORY SYSTEM LOCALLY AND
WITH A LENS ON EQUITY WITH THE
LENS ON THE WORLD AND- LANDS ON
RESILIENCE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
TIME- WE DON'T SEE AN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- THAT WE WANT TO BE A
PART OF WITHOUT THE ARTS. FRONT
AND. CENTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MANAGER. THANK YOU ADAM FELLOW
AND WE ARE HEARING THAT LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT THE ARTS NEED TO
BE PART OF ANY RECOVERY PLAN.
THAT WILL THEN NOW MOVES TO AND
BROWN CRAWFORD WHO IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL WELCOME MAN. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU TO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M AND OUT ACROSS
FRANKLY IT WOULD HAVE HEIR OWN
CAMERAS ON. THERE THERE WE GO
THERE THEN. HI HI AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- THANK
YOU AGAIN. HIS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- AGAIN I'M AND I'M
CRAWFORD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AS
FOURTEEN ARTISTS AND ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE'RE SO GRATEFUL
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO AND
HANK YOU FOR CAN BE. IMPORTANT
HEARING. GET MY SIGN HERE. THAT
WE'RE HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF A
HARD TIME YOU'RE KIND OF GOING
IN AND OUT. I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT I'M- APPEARING HUMBOLDT
COUNTY WHERE. BROADBAND IS
OFTEN AN ISSUE. SO WE SEE A
PRESENTATION LET ME KNOW. OKAY
GOOD GOOD AND THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL IS OUR STATE ONLY
LIKE ARTS GRANT PROVIDER WITH
FUNDING THAT'S ACCEPTABLE TO
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. EVERY
STATE HAS ITS STATE ARTS AGENCY
AS CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
AGENCY REPRIORITIZE RACIAL
EQUITY. AND HAVE A BROAD
GEOGRAPHIC REACH INTO
COMMUNITIES OF ALL SIZES. AS
YOU JUST HEARD THE ARTS SECTOR
IS A LARGE AND DIVERSE IN HIS
BUSINESSES AND WORKFORCE ARE A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR TO OUR
STATE ECONOMY AND OUR IDENTITY.
AS I JOIN YOU HERE TODAY. WE
AND I ARE WE WERE ALL STRUCK BY
THE FIFTH ALWAYS OUR WORLD IS
IN THIS MOMENT FILLED WITH
DEEPLY IMPACTFUL WORDS POETRY
SONG AND SPEECHES OF HOPE
JUSTICE AND RECONCILIATION.
THESE WORDS INCLUDING THOSE
FROM ARE YOU SPEAK TO MEET THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE SWIRLING
ALL AROUND US WITH CLEAR EYES
IN DETERMINATION. AT THE SAME
TIME WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL KNOW FULL WELL
THAT WE FACE HARD WORK TO LIVE
UP TO THE ASPIRATIONS AND HOPE
THAT ALLOWED US A LITTLE BIT OF
SPACE TO BREATHE A BIT MORE
FREELY. YOUR KNOWLEDGE THAT
WE'RE ALL STILL IN THE MIDST OF
SO MANY CRISES. DEADLY VIRUS.
BEST INEQUITIES. SYSTEMIC
RACISM. ECONOMIC DISPARITIES
VIOLENCE AND HATE. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THE PERSISTENCE AND FERVOR
WITH WHICH THE ARTS SECTOR
TACKLE THE PANDEMIC NEARLY A
YEAR AGO STILL REMAINS BUT
WARINESS IS ALSO SEVEN AND
RIGHTLY SO. MY CLIENTS ARE NOT
IF THE FINANCING. STATE THERE
WE GO. EVERYTHING IS LIKE A
LESS THAN TWO WEEKS AGO. THE
WORLD DID NOT KNOW THE NAME
AMANDA GORMAN WITH ONE POLLING
THIS YOUNG ARTIST CALIFORNIA
LIFTED UP THE NATION AND IN
MANY WAYS. HELLO WORLD MACINNES
PROBLEM HE'LL BE FINE EXPRESSED
WHAT SO MANY WORK FEELING SO
MANY THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN SET.
WELL IT ALSO SPOKE HER TRUTH
WITH HONESTY AND CONVICTION IN
NEXT WEEK THE MAP AND IT WILL
BE THE FIRST. TO PERFORM AT THE
SUPER BOWL- HERE WE GO. THOSE
OF US IN THE ARTS ARE NOT
SURPRISED BY THIS WE'RE NOT
SURPRISED A YOUNG ARTISTS CAN
BE STYLISH AND NATION. AS AN
ARTS EDUCATOR THAT WORKED IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA CLICK SCHOOLS
FOR MANY YEARS AND DESIGNED AND
IMPLEMENTED CREATIVE EDUCATION
MODELS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. I'M
NOT SURPRISED THE YOUNG POET IN
CALIFORNIA HAS THE POWER TO
GIVE AN ENTIRE COUNTRY IF THE
HOPE. HEALING AND JOY THROUGH
THEIR WORDS. THAT ARTIST SPOKE
TRUTH. AND THROUGH AMANDA'S
WHERE'S THE POWER OF THE ARTS
REACH THE HEARTS OF PEOPLE
NATIONWIDE INTERFACE SO MANY
OTHERS HAVE FAILED TO DO. BUT
THOSE OF US IN THE ARTS CAN
WELL IMAGINE WHAT IT WOULD BE
LIKE IF AMANDA'S VOICE WAS NOT
ON STAGE. WE CAN IMAGINE THE
HUGE GAPS IN OUR COLLECTIVE
HEALING AND HOPE IF ARTISTS ARE
NOT. SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY ARTS
PROGRAMS IS OFTEN THREATENED IN
PRECARIOUS ROOMS LEFT THOSE
NURTURED MANDATORY. AS A YOUNG
PERSON. WE KNOW THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS EASILY COULD NOT HAVE
EXISTED BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
SEEN AS EASE TENSION. WE KNOW
THAT TOO MANY IN OUR STATE DO
NOT HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. I WANTED
TO TAKE THE TIME TO TALK ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE THIS ONE EXAMPLE
IS ONE POWERFUL YOUNG BOYS
BEAUTIFULLY AND SIMPLY
DEMONSTRATES THE POWER OF THE
ARTS. THIS STORY SPEAKS TO THE
CORE OF WHY THE ARTS ARE YOU
SICK AND SHALL. NOT OPTIONAL.
AND THIS IS WHY OUR ARTS
BUSINESSES AND CULTURAL WORKERS
CANNOT BE LEFT BEHIND HIS
UNPRECEDENTED TIME. AS A SECTOR
IT CONTRIBUTES SO MUCH TO SO
MANY. KOCHAR IS A STRONG
SIGNIFIER OF CALIFORNIA'S
IDENTITY AS A STATE AGENCY THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
SUPPORTS LOCAL EFFORTS
STRUCTURE IN PROGRAMMING
STATEWIDE THROUGH GRANT.
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. S.
CALIFORNIA STATE OUR PATIENTS
SEE THE COUNCIL CONTINUES TO
LEAD EQUITY RETIREMENT
COMMUNITIES WITH THE GREATEST
NEEDS WE SUPPORT LOCAL ARTS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROGRAMMING
IN EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE
THROUGH GRANTS INITIATIVES AND
SERVICES. THE ARTS COUNCIL IS A
TRUSTED RESOURCE FOR THOSE MOST
AFFECTED MICROBIT NINETEEN IN
ACCORDING TO STATE LABOR DATA
THE ARTS SECTOR HAS SOME OF THE
GREATEST JOB LOSSES NATIONWIDE.
STATE EDT DATA SHOWS THAT THE
ARTS ENTERTAINMENT RECREATION
INDUSTRY SAW A DECREASE OF
FORTY POINT 3% IN EMPLOYMENT
FROM MARCH TO AUGUST A LARGER
IMPACT THAN THE 27% DECREASE
SEEN IN THE LEISURE AND
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE.
IT IS GOING TO REPEAT THAT
CALIFORNIA. ARTS SECTOR
EXPERIENCED- FORTY FORTY THREE
DECREASE IN EMPLOYMENT COMPARED
TO THE 27% DECREASE IN THE
HOSPITALITY SECTOR ACCORDING TO
EATING. THERE'S NO DOUBT AT THE
ARTS AS A SECTOR HAS REDUCE THE
PORTION OF THE IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND I KNOW YOU'LL HEAR
MANY MORE DATAPOINTS STORIES
DEMONSTRATING THIS TODAY. OUR
SECTOR HOWEVER IS VITAL TO THE
RELIEF AND RECOVERY EFFORTS OF
THE STATE ARTIST SUPPORT MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH OUTCOMES
AND COMMUNITY RESILIENCE AND
REBUILD. THE CMS AFTER
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES AND THE
SAME NOW. LET'S TAKE A MOMENT
TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
AND HOW WE WORK. THE BUDGET
POLICIES AND ALLOCATIONS FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANT MAKING
ARE. ONE IS APPOINTED BY THE
SENATE. WHEN BY THE ASSEMBLY
AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
THESE ARE DEDICATED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO LEAD OUR PUBLIC
GRANT MAKING PROCESS. AND I AM
PLEASED THAT YOU'LL HEAR FROM
ONE OF OUR COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS. AS A
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTEE I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF OUR STATE
OUR NATION AGENCY AGENCY THREE
SPONSOR HOLE FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF COUNCILS
LOCALIZATIONS GRANT PROGRAMS IN
STATE OPERATIONAL ACTIVITIES.
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. I'LL
SHARE A FEW WORDS ABOUT EACH OF
THESE AREAS IN WHICH WE WORK.
FIRST GRANTS THE COUNCIL INVEST
IN CALIFORNIA UNITY
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL UNITS OF
GOVERNMENT IN CREATIVE
INDIVIDUALS VIA COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED THROUGH A MULTI
STEP PUBLIC PROCESS. THE STAFF
ADMINISTERS THE COUNCIL'S GRANT
PROGRAM. IN RESPONSE TO COPE IN
NINETEEN THE COUNCIL HAS A
STRONG VISION FOR HOW THE
GRANTS WILL BOLSTER RECOVERY TO
PRESERVE JOBS AND STABILIZE
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS WITH EQUITY
THE CENTER. NEXT PROGRAMS
THROUGH AN INTER AGENCY
PARTNERSHIP WITH CDC ARE UNDER
GROWING NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS. WHO COORDINATE
ARTS CLASSES WITH ALL ADULT
CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTIONS IN
THE STATE. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
FIELD THROUGH TERRORISTS
INITIATIVES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS INVOLVED IN.
INCLUDING HOPE THREE OUT LOUD.
THE POET LAUREATE PROGRAM IN
THE STATE CULTURAL DISTRICTS
PROGRAM AMONG OTHERS. AND LOCAL
SERVICES WE ADMINISTER THE
STATE'S LARGEST FREE WEB
DATABASE OF ARTS JOBS AN ARTIST.
OPPORTUNITIES ON OUR WEB SITE.
WE PUBLIC WORKSHOPS INTO
OPPORTUNITIES PRODUCE REPORTS
AND PROVIDE VALUABLE
INFORMATION SERVICES TO THE
PUBLIC INCLUDING A WEEKLY E.
NEWSLETTER. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AND FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT IN THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL. ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND CULTURAL
WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I HOPE FOR TODAY'S
HEARING YOU'LL JOIN IN
BELIEVING THAT CREATING A
BETTER TOMORROW MEANS BEING
HERE FOR THE ARTS TODAY. BEFORE
I PASS IT MIGHT. OUR COUNCIL
CHEERLEADER WE'VE ALSO WAS
SCHEDULED TO SPEAK NEXT IN AND
FORTUNATELY HE'S UNDER THE
WEATHER YOU CAN'T JOIN TODAY
BUT HE EXTENDS HIS GRATITUDE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. YES THE
NEXT YEAR A FEW ITEMS FROM HIS
SCHEDULED REMARKS ABOUT THE
WORK OF THE COUNCIL QUALITY.
YOUR BROWSER WANTED TO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE THAT THE CAAC
STATE BUDGET WAS REDUCED BY
MORE THAN 90% IN TWO THOUSAND
AND THREE. WITH A WIDE REACHING
IMPLICATIONS. FROM TWO THOUSAND
AND THREE TO TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA WAS THE
LAST IN THE NATION IN ARTS
FUNDING PER CAPITA. FIFTEEN
CENTS. A LEVEL PERCENT OF THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF ONE DOLLAR
AND THIRTY FIVE CENTS AT THAT
TIME. THE FIELD STILL VIVIDLY
REMEMBERS THOSE TIMES IN THE
TREMENDOUS LOSS THAT IMPACTED
SO MANY COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT ANY OTHER
FUNDERS TO TAKE PLACE AND- BUT
WHAT THE ARTS COUNCIL HAD BEEN
DOING. IN TRULY IMPACT IS STILL
VISIBLE TODAY IN MANY WAYS. IN
RECENT YEARS THANKS TO THE
SUPPORT OF OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS. WE'VE BEEN REPORTING
A POSITION AS A STATE WIDE FUND
IN MEANINGFUL WAYS. WHEN THE
COUNCIL HELD ITS FIRST VIRTUAL
MEETING LAST APRIL THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT OF THE ARTS
SECTOR WAS IMMEDIATELY
APPARENT. THIS LED THE COUNCIL
TO PRIORITISE CONTINUITY OF
SERVICES WHILE PIVOTING ASK
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE FIELD. IN
MAY. THE COUNCIL VOTED TO
ESTABLISH A ONE MILLION DOLLAR
RAPID RELIEF GRANT FOR FUNDING
INDIVIDUAL ARTISTS. THESE
ARTISTS REPRESENTED
SUFFICIENTLY COMMUNITIES MOST
HIGHLY IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC
ADDRESSING RACIAL INEQUITIES.
IN RECORD TIME THE FUNDS WERE
IN THE HANDS OF ARGUS IN THIS
YEAR THE COUNCIL WAS IN THE
PROCESS ESTABLISH ANOTHER ROUND
OF SIMILAR SUPPORT. THE COUNCIL
ALSO DISTRIBUTED MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN FEDERAL CURES ACT FUNDING
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTY ARTS
PARTNERS. MORE THAN FORTY
COUNTIES OPTED TO DEVELOP RE
GRANTING PROGRAMS FUNDED ARTS
ORGANISATIONS SERVING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR MOST ISSUE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED MY
CODE NINETEEN. AS A QUICKLY GOT
TO WORK ON THEIR NEXT GRANT
CYCLE WHICH IS CURRENTLY OPEN
FOR APPLICATIONS. WE HAD
MULTIPLE PUBLIC LISTENING
SESSIONS LED BY THE COUNCIL TO
DEVELOP NEW GENERAL OPERATING
SUPPORT AND DIRECT GRANTS TO
INDIVIDUALS A SHIFT FROM THE
ARTICLE WAS WRITTEN PROJECT
BASED FUNDING PRIORITIES. IT IS
TALK ABOUT THE ARTS COUNCIL'S
RACER RACIAL EQUITY PRIORITIES.
HER FATHER WANTED TO SHARE THAT
PART OF THE ROLE OF THE
COUNCILMEMBERS INSURING THAT
THE ARTS OF FOR PRIORITIZE
HIGHER STATE. THIS IS REFLECTED
IN OUR NEW MISSION STATEMENT
STRENGTHENING ARTS AND CULTURE
AND CREATIVE EXPRESSION AS A
TOOL TO CULTIVATE. A BETTER
POPCORN YEAH. AND RACIAL EQUITY
STATEMENT AFTER A YEAR LONG
PUBLIC PROCESS. WITH THIS
REMARK THE WAS THE AC COMMITTED
TO ACTIVELY ADDRESSING BARRIERS
TO EQUITY PARTICIPATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THIS REQUIRES
LISTENING CAREFULLY TO
STAKEHOLDERS IN MAKING AND
COMMUNICATING DECISIONS AT SOME
FACETS OF THE PUBLIC MAY
RECESSED. THIS PUBLIC PROCESS
CONFIRMS THAT RACIAL INJUSTICE
MUST BE PRIORITIZED AS IT IS
THE MOST PERVASIVE AND
ENTRENCHED FORM INJUSTICE
PERMEATING THE INSTITUTIONS AND
SYSTEMS THAT EVERYONE LAST
ACCESS. OUR EQUITY GOAL IS TO
CREATE A SENSE OF BELONGING IT
IS SO PROBABLE IT IS
UNIVERSALLY EXPERIENCED.
PURSUIT OF RACIAL JUSTICE
BENEFITS EVERYONE BY TAKING
CRITICAL IT SYSTEMS OF
OPPRESSION. SYSTEMS THAT
UNDERCUTS. ROSS MULTIPLE
DEMOGRAPHICS CONDITIONS AND
EXPERIENCES WELL IN SOME WAYS A
PANDEMIC IS INTERRUPTED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR NEW
FRAMEWORK IS FAIRLY BROUGHT TO
LIGHT THIS PAST YEAR REINFORCE
THE COMMITMENT WE MADE. SHARE
MOTHER RECOGNIZES THE GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND OPPORTUNITY
FACING THE COUNCIL. THIS IS A
PAINFUL TIME FOR ALL OF OUR
GREAT. FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
MANY PARTS OF LOCUSTS AND I'M
TERRIBLY HARD TIME FOR THOSE.
EVEN IT'S COME THEY ARE. YOUR
BROWSER WILL TO THANKS ATKINS
POINTING HIM TO BECOME GET TO
SET. THEIR RIGHT EIGHTY ON THE
ARTS ALWAYS VALUING ARE SO
CONTRIBUTIONS. THANK YOU AGAIN
TO THE CHAIR COMMITTEE FOR
PROVIDING THIS FOR IN FOR
LISTENING TO THE PORTENTS.
ISSUES THROUGH TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU AND ARE NOT ONLY FOR
YOUR BUT OF ALSO FOR LARRY BUZZ
THE- AT. I NEED A- THOSE ARE
VERY SHOCKED NO ONLY OF THE-
THAT WE SELL- BACK EARLIER IN
THE TO BE THE PAN BUT THEN THE
START TO. AND I THINK THAT IS
PART OF OUR ROLE AS A BODY OF
LEGISLATORS IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE LOOK AT INVESTING IN
ARTS NOT BECAUSE OF THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY BUT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT. THAT INVESTMENT IN
TERMS- TURNS INTO JOBS IN
DOLLARS IN OUR ECONOMY. ALL
RIGHT SO NEXT WE HAVE LILIA.
GONZALEZ CHAVEZ WHO IS THE VICE
CHAIR THAT WILL BE PRESENTING.
AND SHE IS THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
WELCOME THE LEAH. HELLO SHARE
TOO MANY MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK TO. I YEAH
GONZALEZ TOP VICE CHAIR
CALIFORNIA PARTS. I AM PLEASED
TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN
TESTIFYING TUESDAY TO THE
CHALLENGES FACED BASED OUR
SECTOR AND TO OUR RESPECTIVE AS
YOUR STATE ARTS COUNCIL. I'M A
NEW MEMBER TO THE ARTS COUNCIL.
APPOINTED BY THE SYSTEM. TWENTY
TWENTY JUST ONE MONTH- REPORT
YEAH YEAH. BUT I'M NOT ME TO
THE ARTS IN CALIFORNIA OR TO
THE STATE PARKS PROCESS AS A
NATIVE OF PRESENT COUNTY I HAVE
AN ACTIVE ADVOCATE ARTS FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS I SERVED ON
BOARD PRESIDENT BARTLET CM AND
THE ORDER FRESNO ARTS COUNCIL
PRIOR TO BEING APPOINTED
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COUNCIL TEN YEARS AGO. I ALSO
SAW AS A- OF GOVERNOR BROWN
WORK. AT THE STATE SUMMER
SCHOOL ARTS. AND I AM ASTOUNDED
MEMBER YEAH. LET THE- CULTURAL
PARTS PRESS THE- AS DIRECTOR
AND BALLOT COOPER SHE OUR
ACCOUNTS HAS STRONG MISSION FOR
HOUSE CA GRANTS TEN BOWLS SIR
RECOVERY TO PRESERVE JOBS AND
WHAT ARTS ORGANIZATIONS. WITH
EQUITY AT THIS. THE IT'S TRUE
THAT ARE. ONLY SELF. WELL WE
CAREFULLY SEE STATE FUND
RETURNED TO PARTS. SEES ME UP
GREAT C. STATE FUNDED CHURCH
IT'S COUNCIL. I WILL ON. AS OUR
PRACTICAL FOR MANY YEARS THE
FOURTEENTH. I HAD WE MIGHT TIME
AND TIME. THAT IT'S NOT NOT.
THE ARTS DOES SO MUCH WITH SO
LITTLE. WATCHING EVERY DOLLAR
OF OUR TWENTY SIX NOW AND WON'T
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION FOR
GRANTS. THE ARTS COUNCIL IS
KNOWN FOR BEING INCREDIBLY
EFFICIENT IN ITS DISTRIBUTION
ROUNDS AND IS RECOGNIZED AS A
MODEL BRENT MAKE BY OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. NO IT'S WON'T THAT
THE AGENCY IS GREATLY OF STAFF
TO SERVE THE LARGEST AND MOST
STATE IN THE NATION. YOU WILL
HEAR TODAY FROM SO MANY AMAZING
THE- AND ORGANIZATION. AND NO
DOUBT NO MANY ORGANIZATIONS I
DON'T WORK WITH YOUR LOCAL. AND
WE HOPE TO HEAR FROM THE- ABOUT
THE GREAT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
THE ARTS COUNCIL SERVES IN THE
WHITE REACH STATE ARTS
INVESTMENT. THE ARTS COUNCIL'S
CURRENT GRANTEES ARE ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DIRECTLY
REPRESENT THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATES COMMUNITIES. WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE VETERANS YOUTH IMPACTED
BY JUSTICE SYSTEM RETURNS
RETURNS CITIZENS CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED. YEAH
OUR CALIFORNIA CONTACT ME OUR
S. T. OPERATE AND DIVERSE
CULTURES REQUIRES ATTENTION I'M
HERE TO CONTINUE TO THRIVE.
WHERE YOU LIVE YOUR RACE YOUR-
SHOULD NOT IMPACT YOUR ABILITY
TO EXPERIENCE THE BENEFITS OF
THE ARTS AND CREATIVE
EXPRESSION. THERE ARE SO MANY
DESPAIR. TO ACCESS TO LOCAL ON.
THIS STATE PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN BRINGING EQUITY TO KEEP
NEED REALITY BASED UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
LIKE THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE LOCAL
PARTNER HEALTH AND ARTS COUNCIL
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN A RECENT
DISTRIBUTION OF FEDERAL. FUNDS
I AM PLEASED TO SHARE THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO LEVERAGE THE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WE
RECEIVED CRAP. AND WE'RE ABLE
TO ADD ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND LOCAL
SUPPORT FOR A TOTAL OF FORTY
THOUSAND TO DISTRIBUTE WITH A
FOCUS ON REACHING PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND UNDERSERVED RURAL
ARTS PROGRAM. A CROSS
CALIFORNIA MARGINALIZED WITH
LIMITED ACCESS TO FUNDS ARE
ALSO THE SAME COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE LIKELY TO FACE SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH EDUCATION
SEARCH FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE AND-
WE ALL KNOW THIS PANDEMIC.
ABSOLUTELY GEOGRAPHIC AND
RACIAL EQUITY WHEN SO MANY. AND
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE YEAH
INSPECTOR RIGHT ARTS WORK
FINDING WAS ALREADY SCARCE BUT
CHAO WELL REPORT. ALL OF THIS.
COMES AT A TIME WHEN THERE IS
AN OUTCRY FROM THIS YEAR THAT
THE ARTS AND CREATIVITY SHOULD
BE FIVE OR TO ALL SECTORS I'M
NOT PRODUCT AS SOMETHING
SEPARATE FROM THE REST OF
FLIGHT. THERE IS A PUSH TO
INCORPORATE ARE MEANINGFUL 'M
COMPLETELY. AB RIGHT THAT
BUYING. ALL RIGHTS AND TO
REGULATE. THAT THE ARTS BE A
TOOL FOR SOLVING PRESS ISSUES A
SEEMS. IF THAT ISN'T. NO ONE
WILL LEFT OUT. MEDIATING ORANGE
OUR- AND IT STEP. WILL HAVE A
TO. THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
EXISTS TO STRENGTHEN OUR PARKS
AND CULTURE AND TO CHAMPION THE
TRUTH ARTS ARE ESSENTIAL NOT.
ADDRESS CHALLENGES FACING OUR
COMMUNITY TODAY AND IN THE
FUTURE. COLLECTIVELY WITH OUR
FAMILY UP IS ARTS FORTY. MUNITY
PARTNERS ALECTINIB. AND THE
ARTS COME AND HELP PRESERVE AND
PROTECT OUR IDENTITY AS
CALIFORNIA. AND PLACE ARTS
CULTURE AND CREATE CREATIVITY
AT THE CENTER OF OUR NEEDS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
OR THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN TWO
DATES ARE IT IS AN HONOR TO BE
PART SUPPORT AND HOW WE CAN ALL
WORK TOGETHER TO BE START ARTS
IN ORDER TO NURTURE. LARGER
SMALL URBAN AND RURAL. ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
LEVY A GONZALEZ TRAVIS VICE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THAT ARE WATCHING AND TO ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS COMING FOR. AND
WE HAVE SET FORTH A VERY ROBUST
AGENDA AND ALREADY HAVE HEARD
INCREDIBLE INFORMATION ON DATA
AND CHARTS AND WHERE WE ARE I
WOULD DO IS MAKE A PLEA TO ALL
OF OUR- PANELISTS COMING FOR.
THAT BUT YOU SPEAK TO
CALIFORNIANS ARE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND IF YOU CAN-
REALLY PAINT THE PICTURE
SPEAKING OF A METAPHOR PAINT
THE PICTURE. OF A STORY AND
TELLING US SOMETHING THAT ARE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE LISTENING
MAY NOT UNDERSTAND ABOUT YOUR
ORGANIZATION MAY NOT UNDERSTAND
BY A GRAPH OR CHART BUT ALSO TO
OUR GOVERNOR'S. OFFICE AND ARE
A LEGISLATORS THAT THEY CAN
REALLY LEAVE HERE WITH A
COMPELLING STORY- USING THE
EXAMPLE OF AMANDA GORMAN. WHICH
WE KNOW AS WE SAW HER SPEAK
LIVE. I KNOW MYSELF I STOPPED
AND I SAT DOWN AND I LISTENED
AND SO UP PLEASE WE WANT TO
KEEP ALL YOUR PRESENTATIONS AND
CHARTS THOSE WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE BUT I'M ASKING IF
YOU'LL JUST SET ASIDE THE
SCRIPT JUST A TINY BIT SO WE
CAN GET EVERYBODY AND WE REALLY
WANT TO GET TO KNOW YOU- BY
YOUR TESTIMONY AND THAT IS NOT
TO SAY WE DO NOT APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY ELSE'S THAT HAVE COME
BEFORE YOU BUT- I'M LOOKING AT
THE TIME AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I LEAVE TODAY WITH A
FACE. AND A STORY FROM YOU SO
I'M JUST ASKING TO CHANGE IT A
LITTLE UP A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE-
I'M A TEACHER BY PROFESSION AND
I JUST I WANT TO GET TO KNOW
YOU SO WHAT. THAT BEING SAID.
WE'RE NEXT CAN INVITE JULIE
BAKER WHO'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FROM THE CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
ARTS AND SO WHAT I'M LOOKING
FOR IS IF YOU'RE WALKING DOWN
THE STREET. AND SOMEBODY SAYS
WHAT DO YOU DO AND WHAT IS YOUR
PASSION AND WHAT DO YOU NEED.
THAT YOU CAN TELL US THAT IN
THREE TO FIVE MINUTES. JULIA OR
JULIE I'M SORRY NINE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME FOR I AM I'M SITTING IN
MY HOME- BUT I WANT TO SAY I
LOVE CALIFORNIA ARTS ANNUAL I
LOVE YOUR MATH THEY WILL TRY TO
BRING IT HOME FOR YOU. I WILL
TRY TO BRING IT HOME FOR YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND
FOR THE PASSION AND COMMITMENT.
YOU'VE SHOWN HER AMAZING ARTS
CULTURE CREATIVITY IN
CALIFORNIA. MY NAME IS JULIE
BAKER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA ARTS
ADVOCATES AND CALIFORNIANS FOR
THE ARTS THE STATE RIGHT ARTS
AND CREATIVE INDUSTRY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS. MY PRONOUNS ARE
SHE HER HERS. AND COMING NEED
TO YOU TODAY. FROM THE LAND OF
THE NEVADA CITY RANCHERIA
NISSAN TRIBE WE'RE CURRENTLY
FIGHTING TO HAVE THE FEDERAL
RECOGNITION RESTORED. LET ME
START BY SHARING A QUOTE BUT
ONE OF MY FAVORITE AUTHORS TONI
MORRISON THAT I THINK
EXEMPLIFIES THIS MOMENT
PERSPECTIVE. QUOTE THIS IS
PRECISELY THE TIME WHEN ARTISTS
GO TO WORK THERE IS NO TIME FOR
DESPAIR NO PLACE FOR SELF PITY.
NO NEED FOR SILENCE NO ROOM FOR
FEAR. WE SPEAK WE WRITE WE DO
LANGUAGE THAT IS HOW
CIVILISATIONS HE'LL AND QUOTE.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A MORE
IMPORTANT AND RELEVANT TIME FOR
THE ARTS AND FOR ARTISTS TO GO
TO WORK TO HEAL AND PROVIDE
EMPATHY HOPE ENJOY. FOR A
NATION DIVIDED AND SICK. IF IT
ANYTIME DURING THE PANDEMIC YOU
I'VE LOOKED UP TO THE WORK OF
ARTISTS TO HELP I NEED. FOR
EVEN A LITTLE DISTRACTION FROM
THE GROUNDHOG DAY NATURE OF
SHELTERING AT HOME. THEN YOU
UNDERSTAND. THE VALUE OF THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS. HELLO WE HAVE
LOW OR ARE FIRST. INCLUDE TO A
YEAR ICE. WE HAVE FAILED TO
SUPPORT RECOGNIZE AND TRULY
VALUED THEM. PARTICULARLY
FINANCIALLY FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS AS OUR NATION'S
SECOND RESPONDERS. WE ARE HERE
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR HELP IN
FINALLY FINALLY ENDING THE
HISTORIC. UNDER CAPITALIZATION
OF THE ARTS WHILE ALSO CREATING
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
TO EMERGE AS A LEADER IN
FOSTERING THE- THRIVING
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES. NOW IS THE
TIME TO PROCLAIM ARTS ARE
ESSENTIAL. AND TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT THAT CAN TRULY MAKE
A DIFFERENCE. WITH THE EXPECTED
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS
THIS ONE TIME BONUS OF BONDS
SHOULD IN PART BE DEDICATED. TO
RESTORING THE CREATIVE
WORKFORCE BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS. CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH.
TO EVERY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA AN INDUSTRY THAT
REPRESENTS OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND JOBS. AND
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. ACCESS ARTS WILL HELP
US SURVIVE AND OVERCOME THE
PANDEMIC AND AS WE EMERGE FROM
THIS CRISIS WILL BE A CHANGE
SOCIETY. INVESTMENT IN THE ARTS
NEED TO BE PART OF A LONG TERM
STRATEGY TO DEAL WITH THE
AFTERMATH OF THE PANDEMIC.
REBUILDING CALIFORNIA WILL
REQUIRE INGENUITY INCLUDING A
RECKONING OF SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS
SUCH AS RACISM AND ECONOMIC
DISPARITY. THE ARTS SECTOR
OFFERS RESOURCEFULNESS AND
INNOVATION OUR VERY NATURE WE
ARE CREATIVE PROBLEM SOLVERS
WHO WILL SHOW UP IN SERVICE TO
REBUILDING OUR COMMUNITIES. WE
HAVE WONDERFUL MODELS ACROSS
THE STATE OF INTEGRATING
SKILLED CREATIVE WORKERS INTO
MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENT STATEWIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS.
PROVIDING EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
AND MENTORSHIP DEVELOPING
THOUGHT PROVOKING AND ORIGINAL
WORKS OF ART TO BUILD EMPATHY
AND BELONGING IN INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES. TO UTILIZE VENUES
AND PERFORMERS UNTIL WE CAN
GATHER SAFELY AGAIN. IT IS TIME
TO BRING THIS TO SCALE ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ONCE WE ARE
ABLE TO GATHER THE ARTS WILL
REIGNITE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE FILLING A RESTAURANTS
HOTELS. AND THEATERS TO
CAPACITY. BUT ARTS AND CULTURAL.
INSTITUTIONS MUST NOT BE
ALLOWED TO. IF WE SEEK TO
RECOVER AND REVITALIZE OUR%
COMMUNITY. WE ARE KEYS TO IN
OUR ECONOMY I. AND SO FABRIC
SUPPORTING THE ARTS HOUSE FOR
IMMEDIATE SOCIAL SERVICES OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WE
CANNOT WAIT ANY LONGER TO
INCREASE FUNDING AND STAFFING
FOR THE STATE ARTS AGENCY THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL. WE
JUST HEARD WE NEED TO FIND THE
BUDGET TO AT LEAST ONE DOLLAR
PER CAPITA PER PERSON WE ARE
CURRENTLY AT SIXTY SIX CENTS
PER PERSON BY COMPARISON. NEW
YORK INVEST TWO DOLLARS AND
THIRTY ONE CENTS AND MINNESOTA.
OVER SEVEN DOLLARS IF
CALIFORNIA IS TRULY GOING TO BE
THE STATE OF THE ARTS WE MUST
DEMONSTRATE COMMITMENT TO ITS
SURVIVAL AND SUSTAINABILITY.
TODAY YOU WILL HEAR STORIES
RESILIENCY AND INNOVATION IN
THE FACE OF SHUT DOWN. AND HOW
ARE CONTINUES TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE SOCIAL
COHESION AND HEALING WHEN YOU
GET THE MOST HOWEVER WHAT YOU
ALSO HERE. IS HOW THIS CRISIS
HAS ALREADY HAS BEEN ALREADY
FINANCIALLY FRAGILE INDUSTRY
MUCH WORSE. EVERY ASPECT OF THE
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN HIT SOME OF
BETTER ACCESS TO CAPITAL
RESERVES SOME OF ACCESS TO
PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY OTHERS
HAVE USED PUBLIC RELIEF FUNDS
TO KEEP GOING. BUT NO ONE HAD
IT IN THEIR STRATEGIC CORPORATE
BUSINESS PLAN HOW TO SURVIVE IF
WE CANNOT EARN REVENUE FOR
TWELVE TO EIGHT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS. THAT'S SIMPLY NOT
TAUGHT IN BUSINESS SCHOOL THE
FUNDING WE'VE RECEIVED THUS FAR
FIRST SECTOR FOR BOTH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND SOME
STATE AND LOCAL FUNDS HAVE HAD
KEPT US ON LIFE SUPPORT. BUT
WILL NOT BE ENOUGH FOR US TO
RETURN TO WORK AND RE OPEN ARTS
SAFELY. PHILANTHROPY HAS
STEPPED UP OF THE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL AS YOU HEARD FROM
BEACON ECONOMICS IS RUNNING DRY
THERE'S ALSO CURRENTLY NO
PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY STATEWIDE
FOR ARTS AND CULTURE. THE ONLY
FUNDING SOURCE OR TO BE
AVAILABLE IN EVERY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA. IS THE STATE ARTS
AGENCY WE CALL UPON THE PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC SECTOR TO INVEST IN
THIS WORK FORCE TO RE BUILD
BACK A BETTER CALIFORNIA ALL.
LET ME JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
DESCRIBE WHO ARE ARTS AND
CULTURE WORKERS TO HAVE AN IDEA
AND THIS COMES FROM OUR
AMERICANS FOR THE ARTS. THE
IMPACT HAS BEEN SIMPLY YOUR-
63% OF CREATE WORKERS WERE AT
THE END 2215% OF CREATIVE
WORKERS SAY THEY DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER FOR
DRINKING OR WASHING ONE IN TEN
CREATIVE WORKERS OF EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS AND ONE OF THREE
IS BEEN ACED WITH THE THREAT
OF EVICTION OVER 50% OF
CREATIVE WORKERS HAVE
EXPERIENCED FOOD INSECURITY AND
40% ARE UNABLE TO GET MEDICAL
HELP AND 55% OF CREATIVE
WORKERS HAVE NO SAVINGS TO FALL
BACK ON. GREAT WORKERS ARE
SUFFERING FROM A LACK OF THE
MOST BASIC HUMAN NEEDS RIGHT
NOW IN FACT- THERE'S SOME OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE WORKFORCE
HONEST AND ARTISTS WHO IDENTIFY
AS BLACK INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR HAVE HIGHER RATES OF
UNEMPLOYMENT THE WHITE ARTISTS
AND WANTS A LARGER. PERCENTAGE
OF THEIR TWENTY TWENTY INCOME-
IT CALIFORNIA'S PICTURES SAME
WITH ONE THIRD OF THE SECTOR
OUT OF WORK. MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND JOBS. AS
YOU HEARD THEIR PARTS WORKERS
MORE THAN THREE TIMES LIKE THE
STUFF AND LLOYD PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE HAS
CREATED A LIFELINE THIRTY
THRESHOLD COULD PANDEMIC COULD
TAKE ON THE SECTOR. YOU KNOW I
WAS GIVEN TEN MINUTES- BY THE
WORK I'M SORRY WE'RE GONNA.
WE'RE GONNA CUT SOME TIME JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY ON OUR
LIST IN AND WE UNDERSTAND BUT I
REALLY HAVE SOMETHING THAT IS
IMPORTANT I'D LIKE TO SHARE
THAN ON THE PURCHASE OF
SPECIFICALLY AT LEAST GET TO
WHAT WE ARE ASKING OF THE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT I CAN GIVE
YOU THE VERY SPECIFICS MAYBE
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. WE HAVE
NO GUIDELINES RIGHT NOW FOR
LIVE PERFORMANCES WE URGE THAT
ARE YOU TO HELP US GET THOSE
GUIDELINES IN COLLABORATION
WITH INDUSTRY EXPERTS YOU WILL
HEAR FROM TODAY. WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING AND RESOURCES
TO REOPEN ARE SAFELY IN THE
FORM OF LOANS OR GRANTS OR
AUDIENCE PERFORMER COBIT
TESTING IN CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
DIRECTOR BIT VENUES IT MAY NOT
HAVE THE VENTILATION SYSTEMS.
TO DEVELOP INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES TO UTILIZE VENUES
FOR VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
DISTRIBUTION SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA CREATED FOR PILOT
PROGRAM AND EXPAND ITS ONGOING
LEGISLATION INCREASE FUNDING
FOR MULTIPLE SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN FORCED TO CLOSE
AN INCREASE OF GOVERNORS-
ALLOCATION TO CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS TO FIFTY MILLION.
AND WE ALSO AGREED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE OF
THE CALIFORNIA GREEK PRIME
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT IT NEEDS TO
BE MORE ON TREND MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO SEE WHO'S
ACTUALLY GETTING THOSE FUNDS.
FINALLY WE URGE POLICY MAKERS
TO CONTINUE DEDICATED STATE AND
FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR. CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES IF AND WHEN SECOND
RELEASE WHICH INCLUDES STATE
FUNDING FOR DEDICATED FUNDING
STREAM. FOR TO CREATE A
BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
STILL CLOSE INCLUDING THE LOCAL
ARTS AGENCIES BUT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND I WILL
HAVE TO PULL A LIST OF THINGS-
SUBMITTED FOR YOUR REVIEW.
THANK YOU. M. THANK YOU WE KNOW
YOU. ALL OF THE PANEL HAVE.
PREPARED FOR THE TIME GIVEN.
AND WE DO. WANT TO. YOUR WORK
ON THAT. ALL OF YOUR REPORTS
AND GRAPHS WILL BE PUT UP ON
OUR- OUR SITE. FOR FURTHER
REFERENCE. AND SO AGAIN AS THE
CHIR OF THIS COMMITTEE. WE DO
WANT TO BE COGNISANT OF WHAT.
REMARKS ARE BEING MADE AHEAD OF
YOU SO IF THERE ARE SOME
SIMILARITIES. IF YOU COULD EDIT
YOUR REMARKS. TO SOME F THE
KEY POINTS THAT POSSIBLY
HAVEN'T ALREADY BEEN SAID. AND
AGAIN BECOME A NARRATIVE. SO
THAT- I THINK AS AS MANY OF US
HERE LISTEN WE CAN SAY. LOOK
LILIA GONZALEZ CHAVEZ SPOKE.
ABOUT JUSTICE AND SPOKE ABOUT
JUSTICE IN THE ARTS AND I THINK
THAT THAT TELLS THE NARRATIVE.
BECAUSE THE MORE WE SPEAK THE
SAME LANGUAGE. AND THE MORE
THAT WE CAN BE OUT THERE WITH
THE POLICE TO CALIFORNIANS-
THAT ARTS ARE NOT JUST ABOUT
CREATIVE INDIVIDUALS. BUT
THEY'RE REALLY ABOUT ARTISTS
WHO ARE. SUPPORTING OUR
ECONOMY. BUT THAT DOES FINISH
OUR FIRST PANEL. AND DO WE HAVE
ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HERE THAT
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS- AND ALSO I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
PALM HARBOR- ASSEMBLY. NAZARIAN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO- COMMAND- THE LAST
COMMENTS MADE BY MISS BAKER-
FIRST OF ALL ON HER POINT ABOUT
A DOLLAR PER PERSON PER CAPITA
INVESTMENT I THINK THAT'S A
CRITICAL INVESTMENT THAT HAS
BEEN SORELY LACKING IN FACT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE FUNDING FOR.
CALIFORNIA ARTS COMMISSION IT
HAD PRETTY MUCH STALLED FOR
ABOUT. TWELVE YEARS- IF I IF
I'M REMEMBERING IT CORRECTLY
EITHER TWELVE OR ELEVEN YEARS
FROM ABOUT TWO THOUSAND- ONTO A
TWO THOUSAND ONE TILL ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE- IN MY FIRST
TERM OF OFFICE I INTRODUCED A
BILL TO EXACTLY DO THAT AND PUT
IN SEVENTY FIVE MILLION- INTO
THE BUDGET ON AN ONGOING BASIS
DOLLAR PER CAPITA BASIS- THAT
ENDED UP BEING NEGOTIATED DOWN
INTO A I THINK A FIVE MILLION
INCREASE AND SLOWLY IT'S BEEN
INCREASING SINCE THEN. BUT WE
NEED TO MAKE THIS PUSH AGAIN
ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME OF
CRISIS WHEN IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE SEE TO WHAT EXTENT OUR STATE
IS DEPENDENT ON THE
ENTERTAINMENT ECONOMY- CREATIVE
ARTS ECONOMY I SHOULD SAY- AND
THE SECOND POINT SHE MADE
ABOUT- THE GUIDELINES THERE'S
SO MANY GUIDELINES SORELY
MISSING BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN.
GOING AS WE'VE AS AS THIS
PANDEMIC HAS EVOLVED AND THE
VIRUS HAS INVOLVED AND THE
SURGES HAVE BEEN. RECURRING
WE'RE TRYING TO GRAPPLE AND
MAKE THINGS AS WE GO ALONG- AND
SO. FROM THE FALL OUT OF THAT
PROCESS WE SEE THAT THEY'RE
SAYING THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
SORELY MISSING AND SOME OF
THESE THINGS MIGHT NOT BE AS A
PARENT IN SOME PARTS OF THE
DISTRICT OF THE STATE BUT IN
PLACES LIKE MYSELF OR MY
DISTRICT OR SEVERAL OTHER
COLLEAGUES DISTRICTS HERE WHEN
YOU HAVE AN ABUNDANCE OF NINETY
NINE SEAT THEATERS OR- A PLACES
THAT- CAPTURED- A LOT OF THESE
UNSPOKEN OR SMALLER SCALE
ECONOMY. BUT VERY MUCH PRESENT-
CONDUCTIVITY SECT THE DIFFERENT
SECTORS OF THE ARTS IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE REGULATIONS IN PLACE SO
THAT PEOPLE GUIDELINES IN PLACE
SO THAT THESE INDUSTRIES CAN
KNOW HOW TO GO ABOUT GETTING RE
SITUATED BACK IN THE ECONOMY
SO- THANK YOU FOR MAKING THOSE
CRITICAL POINTS AND I'M HAPPY
TO. OFFER MY SUPPORT AGAIN- ON
THESE FRONTS AND WORK WITH YOU
AS WELL ALONG WITH OTHER
PANELISTS AND MY COLLEAGUES
HERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THOSE REMARKS AND AGAIN TO-
JULIE BAKER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE ARTS. I
TOO WROTE DOWN THE WORD
GUIDELINES AS I WAS LISTENING
TO YOUR COMMENTS AND ALSO THE
UNDER- WHEN YOU MADE THAT
REMARK ABOUT- OUR STATE IN
FUNDING COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES IT IS- REALLY
DISAPPOINTING- THAT. WE OUGHT
LAGGED FAR BEHIND WHEN WE'RE
ACTUALLY KNOW WHEN. AS THE
ICONIC STATE BUT AGAIN IN MY
AREA HAVING TWO MAJOR THEM
THEME PARKS AND DISNEY
DISNEYLAND AND KNOTT'S BERRY
FARM. IT ISN'T JUST THE THEME
PARK ATTRACTION BUT THEY IN
TURN HIRE MANY MANY HUNDREDS OF
ENTERTAINERS AND PERFORMERS. IN
THOSE THEME PARKS SO WEKNOW
THAT THOSE LOSS OF JOBS OR
SERIOUS. OUT WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
OUR NEXT PANEL AND AGAIN THANK
OUR FIRST PANEL FOR A VERY- WHY
A BIT OF. AND THAT REALLY A SET
THE STAGE FOR WHERE WE ARE AND
TO MOVE INTO OUR NEXT TO PANDA
WHICH IS IMPACTS AN ACT
ACTIVITY. IN THE FIELD SO
HOUSES REALLY PLAYING OUT IN
THE FIELD OUR FIRST SPEAKER WE
HAVE. IS KRISTIN SAID BROKER
WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF ARTS AND
CULTURE- WELCOME CHRISTIAN.
GOOD MORNING ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME THAT'S ME OKAY GREAT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR- AS YOU
NOTED I'M CHRISTIAN CICADA
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF ARTS AND
CULTURE AND I THINK YEAH YOU
AND ALL THE MEMBERS FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK AT THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING. SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF ARTS AND CULTURE
SERVES AS THE LOCAL ARTS AGENCY
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE MOST
POPULOUS AND ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE COUNTIES IN THE NATION-
IN THE LARGEST STATE IN THE
NATION WE HAVE MORE THAN TEN
MILLION RESIDENTS- AND A HUGE
WELL GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY AS
WELL AS CULTURAL AND ETHNIC AND
RACIAL DIVERSITY- IN OUR
COUNTY. AND AS SUCH- WE OFTEN
ARE SORT OF AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT
ELSE IS HAPPENING ALL ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR US
AS A LOCAL ARTS AGENCY OUR ROLE
IS TO DEVELOP COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES IN ARTS
AND CULTURE AND INVEST IN EARLY
COUNTIES CULTURAL LIFE. WE DO
THAT THROUGH A NUMBER OF CORE
AREAS FOR EXAMPLE GRANTS TO
HUNDREDS OF ARTS NONPROFITS AND
SOCIAL SERVICE AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS THAT USE
THE ARTS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT CREATIVE CAREER
PATHWAYS INCLUDING THE PAID
ARTS INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
COMMISSIONING ARTISTS FOR CIVIC
OUR CIVIC SPACES ROBUST ARTS
EDUCATION WHICH IS. SO CRITICAL
TO ALL OF OUR EIGHTY ONE
DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
MORE THAN A MILLION DIFFERENT
STUDENTS AS WELL AS PRODUCING
RESEARCH IN THE ARTS LEADING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE L. A.
COUNTY CULTURAL EQUITY AND
INCLUSION INITIATIVE AND USING
CROSS SECTOR STRATEGIES TO
ADVANCE THE ARTS ACROSS
DIFFERENT SECTORS. WE'RE PROUD
TO SAY WE ARE STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNER OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL. SO I WILL NOT REPEAT
WHAT OTHERS HAVE SAID JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES AT THIS. MOMENT IN
TIME AS A MOMENT OF CRISIS. TO
BE HEALTHCARE. IS A COURSE A
HEALTH CRISIS. OF EPIC
PROPORTIONS HAS LED US TO A
RESULTING ECONOMIC CRISIS AND
WE'VE SEEN DURING THIS TIME A
CRISIS OF RECKONING WITH RACIAL
INEQUITY. AS OTHERS HAVE NOTED
THESE HAVE CAUSED COMBINED- AN
INTENSE AND VERY SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON OUR FIELD SHUTTING
DOWN FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
THE ARTS AND CULTURAL SECTOR-
BUT ALSO DECIMATING MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND REALLY ROUGH.
STRUCTURAL ISSUES THAT WERE
THERE BEFORE SUCH AS THE UNDER
CAPITALIZATION OF THE FIELD
SUCH AS A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT IN INEQUITY ALONG AT
INCOME AND RACIAL LINES INTO
PUBLIC HEALTH. WELL BEING AND
OTHERS BUT I'M GOING TO ADD A
FOURTH CRISIS FOR US TO THINK
ABOUT. AND THAT IS CRISIS
HAPPENING NATIONWIDE. A CRISIS
OF CONFIDENCE IN PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS. AND NOW WHAT ALL
OF THESE HAVE LED US TO. A
MOMENT. OF CRISIS AND RECKONING
IN RESPONSE IT'S ALSO A MOMENT
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
RESPOND FOR US TO RECOVER AND
FOR US TO RE. WHAT'S OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE ARTS AND
CREATIVE SECTOR LOOKS LIKE AND
REIMAGINE THE RESILIENCY. OF
THE ARTS AND CREATIVE SECTOR.
SO JUST BRIEFLY AT THE TOP OF
PART OF WHAT WE DID IS OUR
RESPONSE INCLUDED CONVENING IN
THE ARTS SECTOR WE HAVE OTHER
LOCAL ARTS AGENCIES ARTS
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS GRANTEES
WE PIVOT OUR PROGRAMS TO
VIRTUAL OUT WE XCELERATED GRANT
PAYMENTS TO GET THAT CRITICAL
FUNDING PUBLIC FUNDING OUT THE
DOOR. WE'RE LIAISING WITH THE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO HELP SUPPORT AND
INFORM THEIR EFFORTS- AND HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND THE ARE TO
CREATE A COMEDY AS WELL AS
SHARED THEIR INFORMATION AND
THOSE IMPORTANT PROTOCOLS AND
GUIDES OUT TO THE FIELD.
CREATED DIGITAL RESOURCE
CENTERS AND PARTICIPATED ON L.
A. COUNTY ECONOMIC RESILIENCY
TASK FORCE SOME OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME
THROUGH THAT TASK FORCE ARE
ALREADY BEGINNING TO COME
FORWARD LIKE THE ADOPTION OF A
MODEL COUNTY WHITE CULTURAL
POLICY THAT CENTERS THE NOTION
OF CULTURAL EQUITY FOR ALL. AND
THE IDEA OF THE ARTS AS BEING A
SOLUTION ACROSS SECTORS LIKE
EDUCATION. JUSTICE REFORM THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT AND ANTI
RACISM AND BELONGING. YEAH WE
ALSO WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE CARE ACT DOLLARS AND SO WE
HAD AN L. A. COUNTY KOBE RELIEF
FUND WITH TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WERE GIVEN OUT TO
THE FIELD I WANT TO TELL YOU A
COUPLE OF THINGS ABOUT HOW
THEIR RESPONSE WHEN. WE WERE
ABLE TO GET THOSE FUNDS OUT AND
I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
WE WERE ABLE TO SUPPORT MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE
AFFECTED BY COPING WITH THE
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS EQUITY 95% OF THE
DOLLARS WE GIVE OUT. WITH A
SMALL MID SIZED ORGANIZATIONS
WITH A BUDGET OF FIFTEEN
MILLION AND UNDER KNOWING BILLS
ARE MOST ROOTED OFTEN IN OUR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND HAVE
LESS ACCESS TO FUNDING. BUT
WHAT WE SAW IS THAT THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS APPLYING. THE
FORTY OF THEM HI MY WHEN THEY
PERCENT SAID THEY WERE GOING TO
USE. THOSE DOLLARS FOR PAPER.
AND KEEP JOB. WE ALSO SAW THE
COLLECT UP. THE THREE. OF MORE
THAN HUNDRED OR- APPLYING. THE
LOS. AND AN ANTI. EXPENSES THAT
THEY CLAIMED TOTAL NOT TWELVE
MILLION TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS WHAT IS THE
IMPACT THAT THEY WERE CLAIMING
AND THIS WAS AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY SO AGAIN. WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD WITH EVEN A
LONGER TIME LOSSES SO IT REALLY
SHOWS THE NEED. DEEPLY GRATEFUL
IN THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS RECOGNIZING THE
ARTS SETOR INCLUDING THAT AND
SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF BUT THE
NEED IS STILL GREAT AND
CONTINUING. WE'VE SEEN SO MANY
OF AND LAY OFF STAFF. AND AND
OTHER EXAMPLES OR SHUT DOWN OR
TRYING TO PIVOT TO VIRTUAL HELP
OUR COMMUNITIES WITHOUT BEING
PAID. OR WITHOUT SUPPORT. SO WE
SEE THIS MOMENT AS A TIME NOT
TURN AWAY FROM THE ARTS BUT TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON THE ARTS AS A
VITAL. AND CREATIVE SECTOR
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO OUR SHARED
PROSPERITY IN OUR COLLECTIVE.
RECOVERY HE- AS WE NOTED IN OUR
ECONOMY. BUT ALSO THE ARTS
DISTRIBUTE TO WILL BE
COMMUNITIES. AND STUDIES HAVE
PROVED. AS WELL AS EDUCATE ING
ARGUES. YES I'M SORRY SAY YEAH
WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY SECONDS
LEFT HERE. OKAY THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT SO I WILL JUST
END UP BY SAYING A THREE OUR
OUR AND WE HOPE DEVON THE- OF
THE PUBLIC. AND THE IMPORTANT
ROLE OF THE PUBLIC SECTOR BUT
ALSO KNOW THAT PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP. AND PRIVATE SECTOR
IS CRITICAL AS WELL AND AGAIN
NOTING THAT THE ARTS ARE VITAL
ACROSS SECTORS FROM CAREER
PATHWAYS. TO JUSTICE REFORM
EDUCATION WELL BEING AND SO THE
ARTS ARE A VITAL PART OF RELIEF
BUT ALSO RECOVERY AND
SUPPORTING RE OPENING ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AT D. III
CANNOT BE OVERSTATED SO ALL OF
THAT WITH AN EQUITY LENS. IS
CRITICAL AND THINKING ABOUT THE
ARTS AS PART OF NOT ONLY A
WONDERFUL SECTOR BUT OUR SHARED
PROSPERITY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING O WORKING WITH THE
STATE WE'RE EXCITED TO BE A
PARTNER AND TO REALLY GET TO
WORK WITH ALL OF THE INCREDIBLE
ARTISTS FOR MUSICIANS. ADVOCACY
GROUPS AND PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR ENTITIES I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME AND HAPPY TO
SHARE ANY INFORMATION A
OFFERING THAT I SPOKE ABOUT
TODAY. THEY YOU SO MUCH KRISTIN
SAKODA WE APPRECIATE THOSE. AND
AGAIN AS WE CONTINUE WE STILL
HAVE MANY MANY PRESENTERS I
HAVE NOT COUNTED A MALL BUT WE
HAVE MANY PRESENTERS AND AGAIN.
I WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT THE
LEGISLATORS THAT ARE HERE
LISTENING AND PARTICIPATING. WE
ARE CHAMPIONS FOR THE ARTS WE
WANT TO SEE EVERY ADDITIONAL
DYNAMIC POSSIBLE PUT INTO THIS
BUDGET WE WANT TO SEE RECOVERY
SO WHAT WE'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
YOU OUR SOME SOLUTION- THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
MAY NOT HAVE ALREADY BEEN SAID
SOME KIND OF NARRATIVE AGAIN
STORY THAT MAY HAVE NOT BEEN
SAID- AND ALSO- YOU MIGHT HAVE
TO CUT A FEW OF YOUR SLIDES
AND- SOME OF YOUR PRESENTATION
MORE NOT. AT ALL TRYING. TO
NOT- YOUR TESTIMONY IS A VERY
IMPORTANT WE'RE JUST WANTING TO
TAKE AND UNDERSTOOD. GIVE THE
STORY TO CALIFORNIA IN SNIPPET
HERE SO AS MUCH AS YOU CAN TO
KIND OF AT IT SOME OF YOUR
PRESENTATION WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WE
ARE GOING TO GO NOW TO MARIE
ACOSTA AND SHE EXECUTIVE AND
ARTISTIC DIRECTOR FOR THE
LATINO CENTER FOR ARTS AND
CULTURE. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
I AM GOING TO CUT TO THE CHASE
HERE I HOPE I CAN SHOW YOU OUR
POWER POINT PRESENTATION- BUT
BE VERY BRIEF- AS A AS YOU SAID
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF THE LIKE
YOU KNOW SORT OF OUR CULTURE
LOCATED IN SACRAMENTO- BUT I'M
CURRENTLY THE VOLUNTEER
DIRECTOR. BECAUSE I AM AN
EMPLOYEE. AND I'M AN ELDER I'M
AN OLDER WOMAN IF YOU CAN MAYBE
TELL AND I'M AT THE END OF MY
CAREER AND I FIND MYSELF. NEW
BLOOD AND TRYING TO WANT TO RUN
ONE OF THE OLDEST AND MOST
IMPORTANT CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
LET ME SEE IF I CAN SHOW YOU
ARE SLICE BECAUSE- MINE IS ONE
FACE OF MILLIONS OF FACES OUT
HERE. WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED AND
WORK IN THE ARTS. IS MY
BUSINESS YEAR UP. THERE OKAY GO
STRAIGHT TO OUR SECOND SLIDE
THESE ARE SOME OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WE EMPLOY WERE ONE OF THE
LARGEST NONPROFIT EMPLOYERS OF-
ARTIST IN SACRAMENTO AND YOU
KNOW THE LATINO COMMUNITY'S
BEEN HARD HIT FIFTIES THESE ARE
SOME OF THE FACES- WELL YOU CAN
SEE THE WITH THE MASK BUT THESE
ARE SOME OF THE PEOPLE WE
EMPLOY TRADITIONAL ARTISTS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. OF EMERGING
ARTISTS. FOLK AND TRADITIONAL
ARTISTS THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE WE
PAY. FROM ONE DAY TO THE NEXT
LOST THEIR MONEY THEY LOST
THEIR INCOME. THEY HAD NO TWO
WEEK NOTICE THEY WERE JUST TOLD
US WE HAD TO TELL THEM. NO
MONEY THIS YEAR. AND OUR
VENDORS THESE PEOPLE COME TO
OUR EVENTS MOSTLY OUTDOORS THEY
SELL THEIR WARES EITHER
INDIVIDUAL ARTIST. OR A SMALL
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES FOOD
VENDORS. AND THEY MAKE A LOT OF
MONEY IN OUR BEDS BECAUSE THEY
SELL. MOST OF WHAT THEY MAKE.
RESTAURANTS THESE ARE
RESTAURANTS IN SACRAMENTO
THEY'RE CLOSED BUT THIS IS ONE
THAT IS RIGHT NEAR WHERE WE DO
DAVID YET. AND THEY RELY ON OUR
INCOME WHEN WE GET THERE OKAY
HERE'S A SLICE IT SHOULD WAKE
EVERYBODY UP. DEPARTING YES WE
ARE PAPER PORTAPOTTIES EVERYONE
OF OUR AFTER EVENTS ARE POURED
PARTY PROVIDER IS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNED BY A PERON OF
COLOR. AND THEY RELY ON US FOR
INCOME SO- THIS IS ONE OF THE
FAR REACHES THAT. THAT THE ARTS
AND PASSED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MARIE I YEAH
THIS IS SOMETHING I APPRECIATE
BECAUSE- I DON'T THINK ANYBODY.
WOULD ASSOCIATE PORTAPOTTIES
WITH THE ART. SO YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A VENDOR THAT WE- WOULD
NOT BE ON OUR RADAR SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND THAT'S THE
KIND OF THINGS THAT WE WANT TO
HEAR IS SOMETHING THAT WE MIGHT
NOT HAVE ALREADY HEARD SO THANK
YOU- AND IF YOU WANT TO
CONTINUE TO- IF YOU HAVE ANY
SOLUTIONS THAT YOU'VE REALLY
BEEN THINKING I GUESS I'M
GETTING. THAT RIGHT NOW MANAGER
THANK YOU TO PICTURE MY
FAMILIES THIS IS OUR SOLUTION
WHICH THAT WE WANT TO CLOSE TO
YOU. WE WERE FUNDED BY
SACRAMENTO TO DID SACRAMENTO
ARTIST CORE ARTIST CORPORATE
FORTY ARTISTS TO WORK. AND AND
THESE AE ARTISTS WE LOST ALL
OF THEIR INCOME SYSTEM A
DEPRESSED WE GOT. THIS IS A
COLORING BOOK THAT I'D LIKE TO
SHOW YOU THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED
TO FOOD BANKS AND SHELTERS-
JUDGE DISTRIBUTION CENTERS. IT
WAS CREATED FOR FAMILY MARIA
SOMEHOW YOUR SLIDES AREN'T
SHOWING UP MAYBE THAT'S. A
LITTLE BIT. YEAH THEY'RE NOT.
THE COLORING BOOKS IT CAN'T BE
SEEN. NO WORD WE'RE NOT SEEN
THIS SO IF YOU WANTED US JUST
TELL US WHAT. HELP L. GIVE THIS
YOU IS AN EXAMPLE ONE OF THE
THAT ARTISTS WERE PUT TO WORK
JUST SERVE OUR COMMUNITY DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING PUT US TO WORK
WHAT IS TO WORK FUND DOES GET
US BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE- BY
STARTING A PROJECT STATEWIDE
THAT I UNDERSTAND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THE
CALIFORNIA CREATIVE CORE. WHAT
IS TO WORK AND YOU'LL SEE
RESULTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE
SLIDES FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY
DIDN'T POP UP- WE'LL MAKE SURE
THEY'RE IN THE IN OUR WEB OUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU MARIA
AND WE DO APPRECIATE THOSE. I
HEAR YOU CLEARLY GET US THE
RESOURCES SO WE CAN GET BACK TO
WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT NOW NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO KISHA DUMAS WHO IT
FEATURED IMAGE HE WHO IS A
DIRECTOR OF THE MUSEUM OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN ART AND AGAIN
HE SHOOK IF U. P. JUST GIVE US
A FEW EXAMPLES WE KNOW THAT
ABOUT THREE FOURTHS OF YOUR
PRESENTATIONS HAVE TO BE CUT
BECAUSE OF TIME BUT- WE WANT TO
HEAR JEFF. YOUR PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING KISHA. GOOD MORNING CAN
YOU HEAR ME. I APOLOGIZE FOR
HAVING SOME THERE SHE IS GOOD
MORNING CATIA THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
AND TO THE CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PERKS OVER FOR YOUR
EFFORTS TO LISTEN TO ALL VOICES
AT TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON RESTARTING THE ARTS
AS I SUBMIT THIS FORMAL
TESTIMONY I HOPE THE COMMITTEE
WILL FORGIVE THE TIME. BECAUSE
YOU'RE INSPIRED BY THE ARTS AND
WE ALL LISTEN MORE CLOSELY WHEN
WORDS RHYME TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COM LOCKER WHO HAS BEEN
LISTENING FROM THE START
READINGS FROM THE FIFTY FOURTH
DISTRICT AND THE MUSEUM OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN ART OUR
MEMBERS ARE DYING. MANY FROM
COVERT NINETEEN OTHERS FROM
GOOD OLD AGE STILL MORE FROM
ISOLATION UNEMPLOYMENT AND
REYES WE'VE SHOWNOUR LONGEVITY
AND NOW THERE'S A NECESSITY FOR
OUR MUSEUM TO SEE FUNDING IN
WAYS WE MIGHT NOT HAVE BEFORE
SO THAT WE WON'T BE IGNORED.
ALL THE ARTS ARE EQUALLY
ESSENTIAL AND BUDGET SIZE IS
NOT A CREDENTIAL WE WANT TO BE
ELIGIBLE. EVEN IF OUR BUDGET
SEEMS NEGLIGIBLE IN GRANT
MAKING CIRCLES THERE SEEMS TO
BE SOME FEAR THAT IF YOUR
ORGANIZATION IS SMALL HE MIGHT
DISAPPEAR LET US COUNTER THAT
NOTION. WE ARE STILL HERE THE
MUSEUM OF AFRICAN AMERICAN ART
IS IN ITS FORTY FIFTH YEAR WE
RECEIVED A SMALL CARES RECOVERY
GRANT AND WILL CONTINUE TO
APPLY. FOR ALL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WHICH WE
QUALIFY OUR REVENUES SINCE THE
SHUTDOWN HAVE DECREASED BY 68%
FOR RENTALS GIFT SHOP SALES AND
MEMBERSHIPS WHICH ALL RELIED ON
IN PERSON EVENTS WHEN WE HOST
EVENTS WE OFFER FOOD. SOME
PEOPLE COME FOR THE TURKEY
WRAPS OR SEND THEIR KIDS INTO
THE MUSEUM FOR A MUCH NEEDED
SNACK BECAUSE WE DON'T TURN OUR
BACKS ANYONE CAN VISIT FOR FREE
AND NO ONE WILL ASK FOR THEIR
TICKET OR THEIR STICKER. OR FOR
THEIR PATH NO ONE WILL TURN
THEM AWAY OR ASK THEM TO LEAVE
WE SAY THANK YOU FOR COMING
ENJOY THE ART PLEASE WHEN THE
EVENT IS ENDING WE ASK WHY
DON'T YOU WAIT. JUST A FEW MORE
MINUTES AND TAKE HOME A PLATE
NOW WE'RE PLANNING VIRTUALLY
VENTS AND LAUNCHING NEW
COMMUNICATIONS SEEKING FUNDING
NOT FOR PROJECTS BUT FOR RE
OPENING AND OPERATIONS WE'VE
BEEN SHATTERED. AND THE
GUIDELINES FOR RE OPENING HAVE
SEEN AND CLATTERED WE ARE
INSIDE A RETAIL SPACE THAT IS
OPEN PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY WE'RE CLOSE. DOES ONE
GUIDELINE FIT ALL MUSEUMS
THAT'S ONE OF THE QUESTIONS WE
POSE WHEN IT'S ALL DONE AND
SPOKEN WE WOULD LIKE TO REOPEN.
EVEN FOR LIMITED ACTIVITIES WE
CAN BE PART OF THE REMEDY WE
ARE AN ART. MUSEUM INSIDE A
RETAIL PLACE AS COMPEL TO READ
UP HOW WE USE OURS. OUR LARGE
EVENT HALL IS ONE OF OUR FEW
SURPLUSES AND WE COULD BE OPEN
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH PURPOSES
METRO CENTER THEATRE GROUP AND
THE COMMISSIONERS OF LOS
ANGELES POLICE. HAVE ALL COME
TO OUR MUSEUM FOR COMMUNITY OUT
REACH WERE READY TO ACTIVATE
THAT SAME OUTRAGE MACHINE TO
HELP THE MUSEUM'S NEIGHBORS GET
THAT VACCINE WE DON'T HAVE AN
ENDOWMENT. WHAT WE HAVE IS
EMPOWERMENT FROM THE COMMUNITY
THAT TRUST US. TO EDUCATE
CREATIVELY FROM HEALTH TO
SOCIAL JUSTICE WE ARE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF AN ART
ECOSYSTEM. THAT IS NOT YET AN
EQUAL SYSTEM IT'S STILL
DISCRIMINATES. ON THE BASIS OF
SIZE WE ASK YOU TO REVISE YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE AN ANCHOR. INSTITUTION
MUSEUMS OF ALL SIZES CAN BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION. EVEN ON
THE SMALLEST BUDGET WE WILL BE
WITH OUR TWO CENTS. THE ARTS
ARE FEEDING YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN CALLED THE
STATE OF THE ART AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LEGISLATE
ACCORDINGLY THANK YOU. WOW THAT
WAS AWESOME THAT WAS INCREDIBLE
THANK YOU AND- I THINK YOU
SUMMED UP. AND AGAIN IT GOES
BACK- IF THE GOVERNOR'S TEAM IS
WATCHING AND LISTENING IT GOES
BACK TO GUIDELINES GUIDELINES
GUIDELINES I NOTED. THE SPACE
THAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
THAT- YOU ARE IN A RETAIL SPACE
AND- YOU'RE ALSO LOOKING TO DO
THINGS RELATED TO VACCINES AND
DEAD. I THINK IT'S VERY
COMPELLING THANK YOU WE WILL IF
YOU WOULD NOT MIND ALLOWING US
TO HAVE THAT SCRIPT OR IF YOU
WANT TO SAY POEM- VERY
BRILLIANTLY WRITTEN WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THAT TO
DOCTOR MACAULAY. AND A FEW OF
OUR GOVERNOR'S TEAM THANK YOU
SO MUCH UP WITH THAT-
APPRECIATE THAT AND THAT WAS-
THE- TESTIMONY OF THE ART FAIR
THANK YOU FUCHSIA- NEXT WE HAVE
BRITNEY BRITAIN WHO IS THE
GALLERY DIRECTOR- ES EL LET ME
SAY THE NATIVE AMERICAN ART
GALLERIES. AND- WE WELCOME.
BRITNEY BRITAIN. HEY I'M SIXTY
YET HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY- UNWRITTEN
BRENDA GALLERY DIRECTOR TO BE
STOLEN AND THE TEENAGER
AMERICAN ART GALLERIES LOCATED
AT THE WHOLE STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS HERE MARKETING
CALIFORNIA. AN ANCESTOR WE OUR
TERRITORY. I AM ALSO A COOPER
TRIBAL MEMBER HEADING PLEASED
TO BE ABLE TO REPORT TO YOU ALL
ON THE STATE OF THE GALLERY OUR
OTHER LARA LOCAL ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS. HERE IN A RURAL
INTER TRIBAL COMMUNITIES- I'M
NOT SURE IN WHAT I HAD PREPARED
PREVIOUSLY- BUT MY FOCUS IS
HERE ARE THE STRUGGLES OVER
RURAL COMMUNITIES HERE UP NORTH
AND IN OTHER PARTS OF OUR
STATE. THAT OUR INTERNET ACCESS
COMIC AISLING STRUGGLES AND
FUNDING AS OTHERS WHO
PREVIOUSLY SAID- I'M IN THE
UNIQUE POSITION AS BEING A
DIRECTOR OF TO ART GALLERIES
HOUSED ON THE CSU CAMPUS OF THE
RESPONDENTS ARE ACTIVE GALLERY.
AB DE IS OUR NEW AMERICAN ARTS
GALLERY IS THE ONLY NEEDED
BECAUSE GALLERIES UC SYSTEM
PROBABLY ONE OF THE FEW NEED
EFFECTIVE CALORIES WITHIN
CALIFORNIA- I CAME OUT OF A JOB
IN JUNE OF LAST YEAR I MEAN
STUFF OF ONE TRYING TO SHIFT
OUR EXHIBITIONS AS EVERYBODY
IS. AN TO DIGITAL AND MEDIA
OUTDOOR SPACES. WHERE THEY CAN
BE SEEN. I YOU ARE. OKAY WE
HAVE. A DOUBLE SWORD KOBE. WE
HAVE ACCESS A WIDER OPENS THE
NOT HAVE AN TO. THAT HELP
CONNECT US- WE A LOWER CASE
RATES IN GENERAL AND HUMBLE
COMPARED THE REST OF THE STATE.
AND EASE OF FINDING AREAS
PEOPLE RECREATION AND CREATE
WITHOUT HAVING TO GATHER WITH
OTHERS- BUT WE ALSO HAVE
LIMITED INTERNET ACCESS IN
ORDER. I HAVE RURAL INNER
SPECIALLY OR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
I LIKE WE SAW WITH AND CRAWFORD
REPORTING FROM MARQUITA AND I
MIGHT BE HAVING SIMILAR ISSUES
HERE. OUT ON THE COAST. MORE
INFORMATION BUT THE ONLY ACCESS
FOR INTERNET IS EITHER
SATELLITE. OR THE USE OF MY
CELL PHONE AS A HOT SPOT. I
MEAN THIS IS NOT AN UNCOMMON
EXPERIENCE HERE UP NORTH- ADDED
ISSUES WITHIN THAT ARE THE
ELDERS WERE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY AND MORE
LIKELY TO NEED TO BE CONNECTED
TO OTHERS. HOW DO WE GET ARTS
PROGRAMS. AND PROGRAMMING. TO
ALL PARTS OF OUR STATE- WHEN
CAME INTO JOB HAD CAN. OUR OVER
SPUR PROGRAMMING AND- TO.
PROGRAMMING I MEAN THE DECISION
TO VISIT INSTALL OR EXHIBITIONS
BY MYSELF INTO ART GALLERIES.
AND USING THREE SIXTY
PHOTOGRAPHING TO CAPTURE THE
EXHIBITIONS IN PLACE TO SHOW TO
CHILDREN. ALONG WITH. DIGITAL
TO WORKERS- KIDDING. WITH EASY
FOR ME AS I BACKSPACE YES YOU
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE EXPERIENCING.
FUNDING CRISIS. THE PURCHASE A
VERY. THREE SIXTY CAMERA IS NOT
SOMETHING ALL OVER RURAL ARTS
OR ARE ABLE TO DO- WE HAD A
COMMUNITY EXHIBITIONS OVER THE
SUMMER AND FALL. TO AN ONLINE
SPACE IN A WAY THAT HELPS SELL
ARTISTS ARTWORK AND THEY HAVE
HAD LOTS OF SUCCESS WITH THAT I
BOUGHT A PAINTING FROM THERE-
FOR MY HEART I'VE HAD TO KEEP
THE RESPOND AND IF YOU DO YOU
CLOSE TO THE PUBLIC DUE TO
BEING ON A CC CAMPUS- WHILE
OTHER DOLLARS IN THESE UNITS IN
THE COUNTY OF HUMPHREY FURIOUS
AT BEING ABLE TO. USE THAT
TOPIC HERE'S WHERE WE
EXPERIENCE LIMITATIONS WITHIN
CURRENT GUIDELINES ON USING
GALLERIES ARE BEING CONSIDERED
A PART IN YOUR ENTERTAINMENT.
THE CLERK HISTORICAL MUSEUM
WHICH FOCUSES ON HOW HISTORY
WITH A FANTASTIC REQUEST NEED
AMERICAN BASKET COLLECTION
WASTE WORK UNTIL JUNE OF LAST
YEAR. WAS MADE TO CLOSE WHILE
PURPLE TEARFUL RETAIL SPACES IN
MALLS ARE LIKE. LITTLE ON
RESTAURANTS. YOU ARE ASKED OF
THEIR OUT TO SPACES WHICH ALLOW
OF OUR- HAS. ME ARE INDOOR ONLY
SPACES. DUE TO THE NATURE THEIR
COLLECT. AND THEIR ARCHETYPE.
OUR SMALL WORLD MUSEUM AND ARE
GALLERIES AREN'T BEING TO CAN.
THESE GUYS. I WOULD ARGUABLY
FEEL SAFER GOING INTO ONE OF
OUR HISTORY OR ART GALLERIES.
WITH AN APPOINTMENT FIRST THE
SHOPPING AT A MALL IN THE SAME
IN THE SAME AYE RISKS HERE.
THIS CREATED A STRUGGLE TO GIVE
ARTISTS SPACES TO SHOWCASE OUR
WORK AND HAVING TO WORK
CREATIVELY WITH IN STRICT
CONSTRAINTS. ON WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM OUR OTHER LOCAL
ARTISTS WORK SOMEONE ALONG WITH
WHAT I'M SEEING MYSELF- LOOKING
INTO THIS NEXT YEAR. IS THAT
THERE'S A LIMITED ACCESS TO
FUNDING LIKE. OTHER OTHER PEERS
HAVE SAID- THERE'S A LOT OF
FUNDING NEED FOR NORMAN CAL.
BUT LARGER MORE. AREAS RISK
THIRTY FIVE. MORE EASILY US FOR
THEIR NORTH OF FUNDING THAT
COMES INTO OUR ROUTINE STATE IN
A REAL COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OUR
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS WORK
TOGETHER AND EMPLOY ARTISTS
FIRST. WE NEED TO MAKE THE ARTS
ACCESSIBLE AND GETTING MONEY
INTO THE HANDS OF ARTISTS- I
HAVE TO BRING MY ARTWORK INTO
THE COMMUNITY WE HAVE TO BE
CREATIVE WITH OUR PROBLEM
SOLVING. THERE'S A STRAIGHT
ZERO COMMUNITY BEING ABLE TO
MAKE DO WITH WHAT WE HAD AND
STILL BE ABLE TO KEEP THINGS
GOING. THE ARTS ARE INTEGRAL TO
OUR COMMUNITIES OUR CULTURES
ARE WAYS IN WHICH WE VIEW REYES
OF BEING AN APPEALING. AND SAID
YES THANK YOU FOR MY WE'RE
GIVING ME THIS TIME AND- YET.
THANK YOU BRITNEY. AND AGAIN I
AM HEARING. BECAUSE OF WHERE
YOUR GALLERIES ARE LOCATED ON
CAMPUSES THAT'S BEEN A VERY
YEAR- THAT- YOU PIVOTED TO FLY.
USING SOME THREE D. PRINTERS
WHICH I KNOW THOSE ARE VERY
COSTLY BUT ULTIMATELY WE NEED
TO GET. THE ART ARTISTS AND
THEIR WARES TO THE PUBLIC AND
THAT GOES BACK TO GUIDELINES
RIGHT. SO WE ARE GOING TO BE
THE BROKEN RECORD ON GUIDELINES
IF NOTHING ELSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE TO JAIL-
JOANNE DESMOND THE SYSTEM
BUSINESS AGENT NOW FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL ALLIANCE OF
THEATRICAL STAGE EMPLOYEES
LOCAL SIXTEEN. SO THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORKING ON THE FRONT
LINES. GOOD MORNING I HOPE
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR ME. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE HEAR YOU AND
SEE YOU WELCOME. GREAT THANK
YOU DO YOUR CHAIR QUIRKS SILVA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JOANNE DESMOND AND I
REPRESENT AYE ATSC LOCAL
SIXTEEN STATE CHANCE IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. WE ARE ALSO
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA IATSE
COUNCIL WE ARE DEEPLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY AND YOUR
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF OUR SITUATION. WHEN KOBE
NINETEEN HIT ALMOST A YEAR AGO
STATE CHANCE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SO THEIR WORK
DISAPPEAR LITERALLY OVERNIGHT.
CARPENTERS RIGGERS PAINTERS
AUDIOVISUAL TECHNICIANS
ELECTRICIANS WARDROBE HAIR AND
MAKEUP HAS BEEN LEFT DEVASTATED
DUE TO THIS CRISIS CURRENTLY
OUR WORKFORCE IS AT. 95%
UNEMPLOYMENT. JUST THE CITY IS
CALLOUSED ISN'T UNDERSTATEMENT.
WHAT IS THE NAME THEIR UNDER
THEIR APPOINTMENT IS JUST THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG FOR SO MANY.
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF OUR
MEMBERS. HAVE ALSO LOST THEIR
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE DUE TO LACK
OF CONTRIBUTIONS. MANY HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO MOVE OUT OF
STATE TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY.
AND WE'RE DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
PAY BACK RENT. ALL THIS IS
HAPPENING WELL THEY ARE FORCED
TO DECIDE IF THEY STILL HAVE A
FUTURE IN A CAREER THEY LOVE
AND HAVE DEDICATED THEIR LIVES
TO. IN ADDITION CALIFORNIA
MEDIJI HAS PROVED TO BE
CHALLENGING AND FRUSTRATING TO
FAR TOO MANY WHO HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO ACCESS THEIR
BENEFITS. FOR THEM UNEMPLOYMENT.
IS CURRENTLY YOUR ONLY SOURCE
OF INCOME. LASTLY AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY THE EFFECT THIS
HAS TAKEN ON A MEMBERS MENTAL
HEALTH CANNOT BE OVERLOOKED.
SADLY WE HAVE PROOF OF THAT
REALITY. SINCE WE HAVE
ENCOUNTERED SEVERAL SUICIDES
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC AND THE
DISASTROUS SITUATION IT HAS
CREATED. I EIGHTY IS THE LOCAL
SIXTEEN HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO ASSIST OUR MEMBERS DURING
THIS TIME WE ARE HELPING THEM
NAVIGATE EDT WE WRITE READ
RELEASED LETTERS TO LANDLORDS
WE CONTRIBUTE TO AND STAFF FOOD
BANK DRIVES. YET DUE TO THE
FACT WE ARE UNION FIVE OH ONE
C. FIVE WE HAVE REMADE IN
ELIGIBLE FOR CRUCIAL FUNDS FROM
THE PAYMENT PROTECTION PROGRAM
THE EFFORTS TO INCLUDE UNIONS
IN THE LAST STIMULUS BILL WERE
BLOCKED. LOCAL SIXTEEN IS A
LABOR UNION COMMITTED TO
ASSISTING NOT JUST OUR MEMBERS
BUT ALL WORKING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATED BY COVERT
NINETEEN. HOWEVER WE NEED
PRELIMINARY GUIDELINES FOR THE
CRITERIA WE WILL NEED FOR LIVE
ENTERTAINMENT TO REOPEN. WELL
THE FEDERAL STIMULUS PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN HELPFUL THEY ARE FAR
FROM ENOUGH WE NEED ECONOMIC
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
ARTS AND ENTERTAINMENT TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. WE NEED TO
CREATE NON REFUNDABLE TAX
CREDITS FOR BUSINESSES TO COVER
THE COST OF CODE NINETEEN
WORKPLACE SAFETY COMPLIANCE. WE
NEED UNIONS GROUP WE'RE A FEW
PEOPLE PROGRAM. WE NEED TO
PRESERVE OUR PRESERVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE BE A 1100% FEDERAL
COCOPAH SUBSIDY FOR WORKERS. WE
ARE WORKING HARD TO ENSURE THAT
THESE AND OTHER POSITION-
PROVISIONS ARE IN THE NEXT TO
ME IT WAS BUILT. THE SUPPORT OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR OUR EFFORTS
WOULD BE INVALUABLE IT WOULD
HELP US AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
LOOKING TO THE FUTURE THE
PERFORMING ARTS MUSIC AND LIVE
ENTERTAINMENT ARE ESSENTIAL TO
THE ECONOMIC AS WELL AS
CULTURAL WELL BEING. OF
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING.
THAT THE SOONER WE CAN GET THE
SECTOR BACK TO WORK THE SOONER
OUR STATE CAN BEGIN STRONG
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WELL FACING
ALL THIS I EIGHTY LOCAL SIXTEEN
AND OUR MEMBERS ARE READY TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION.
STAGEHANDS ARE ONE OF THE MOST
VERSATILE LABOR FORCES IN THE
COUNTRY. THE CALIFORNIAATSC
COUNCIL HAS REACHED OUT TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM TO OFFER OUR
ASSISTANCE IN THE SETTING UP OF
LARGE SCALE VACCINATION SITES
AT VARIOUS VENUES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE READY ABLE
AND WILLING TO HELP WE WELCOME
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JOANNE AND WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR COMMENTS
AGAIN YOUR INITIAL COMMENTS
NOTED- SO MANY. JOBS THAT NOT
ALL WE ARE WE ASSOCIATING WITH
THE ARTS INDUSTRY WHETHER IT'S
CARPENTERS ARE PAINTERS ARE
BUILDERS OF SAT. AND WE KNOW
THAT THEY LIKE YOU SAID 95%
UNEMPLOYMENT LOSING HEALTHCARE
THESE ARE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES
AND- WE DO URGE THOSE OUT THERE
LISTENING TO CONTINUE TO APPLY
FOR THE PP PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. TO- ASK FOR
ASSISTANCE THROUGH ET DE WE
KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN AN
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT PROCESS
AND- MANY MANY OF US AS
LEGISLATORS AR VERY CONCERNED
BUT WE CAN HELP NAVIGATE. WHERE
POSSIBLE- BUT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO SEND THE MESSAGE THAT WE
NEED TO REOPEN WITH GUIDELINES
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THAT DOES AND THAT
SECOND PANEL WE NEXT TAB OR
THIRD PANEL WHICH IS RESTART
THE ARTS RE OPENING SAFELY
BEFORE WE BEGAN I KNOW THAT OUR-
AKIS DOES HAVE A CALL AT NOON
SO WE WILL BE LOSING SOME OF
OUR MEMBERS SO I APOLOGIZE. TO
US SOME OF THE SPEAKERS IF YOU
SEEN MY URGENCY AND BREVITY IT
IS NOT BECAUSE THEY DON'T VALUE
YOUR COMMENTS I JUST WANT OUR
MEMBERS TO GET AS MUCH OF. YOUR
COMMENTS AS POSSIBLE BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE AFTERNOON. EVEN
IF SOME OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE TO
LEAVE SO DO WE HAVE ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE THAT HAVE
ANY COMMENTS THAT THEY ONE
MIGHT ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO
THE NEXT THIRD. UP CAMEL AND WE
HAVE EIGHT PRESENTERS ON HERE.
AND THIS IS TITLE RESTART THE
ARTS RE OPENING SAFELY WHICH
HAS BEEN OUR GOAL FROM DAY ONE.
AND WE ARE GONNA START WITH
MARK THE DAM SAID WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE- THEATRICAL
PRODUCERS A LEAGUE OF LOS
ANGELES MARK THE- GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR INCLUDING ME IN THIS
MORNING'S HEARING AND FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE ARTS YES MY
NAME IS MARTHA DENSON I AM THE
BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
THEATRICAL PRODUCERS LEAGUE OF
LOS ANGELES WHICH IS A TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF SMALL AND MID
SIZE NONPROFIT THEATERS. WE ARE
YOUNG JUST UNDER TEN YEARS OLD
BUT TOGETHER OUR MEMBER
ORGANISATIONS FUEL THE ENGINE
THAT THAT THAT DRIVES THE
DREAMS OF EMERGING AND BY PARK
ARTISTS WHO NEED A PLACE WHERE
THEIR VOICES CAN BE HEARD. FOR
THEIR WORK CAN BE CHAMPION AND
WHERE THEY CAN MAKE CONNECTIONS
AND ADVANCE CAREERS WITHOUT
ENCOUNTERING THE PAY WALL OF
CASTING DIRECTOR WORKSHOPS OR
EXPENSIVE SHOWCASES. SHORTLY
AFTER THAT THE PANDEMIC BEGAN I
BECAME DEEPLY CONCERNED WITH
THIS QUESTION OF HOW WE NEED A
PERFORMING ARTS COMMUNITY WOULD
COME BACK FROM COVE IT. HOW
WOULD WE KEEP ARTISTS AND
PATRONS SAFE HOW WOULD WE
CONVINCE THEM THAT WE COULD DO
SO HOW COULD WE MAKE EVERYONE
FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT WE WERE
DOING SO. I DECIDED THAT
TEMPLATE SHOULD REACH OUT TO
OUR THEATRICAL LABOR UNION
PARTNERS TO FORMULATE A PLAN.
THEY EACH HAD RETAIN NOTABLE
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS AND I THOUGHT.
IF I COULD CONVINCE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM EACH LABOR
UNION TO JOIN ME IN A ROOM
TOGETHER WE COULD ASSEMBLE
COMPREHENSIVE GUIDELINES
ADDRESSING THE SAFETY NEEDS AND
COCERNS OF ALL THE ARTISTS WHO
COLLABORATE IN THE CREATION OF
LIVE PERFORMANCE. AND WHOSE
WORK PUTS THEM ESPECIALLY AT
RISK IT TOOK A LITTLE
PERSUASION BUT FINALLY OUR
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT CODE
SAFETY TASK FORCE WAS
ASSEMBLED. AND AS FAR AS I KNOW
OUR TASK FORCE IS THE ONLY ONE
OF ITS KIND IN THE COUNTRY FOR
OUR INDUSTRY WHERE
REPRESENTATIVES OF EACH UNION
HAVE SAT DOWN WITH EACH OTHER.
AND WITH PRODUCERS TO WORK ON A
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF SAFETY
RECOMMENDATIONS. EVEN THOUGH IT
WAS COMPANIES ARE SMALL I
BELIEVE WE ARE UNIQUELY WELL
POSITIONED TO RESPOND TO THE
KOBE CRISIS. I DON'T THINK MANY
AT THIS TIME WOULD FEEL
COMFORTABLE ATTENDING A POP
CONCERT OR A HUGE TOURING
PRODUCTIONS. BUT WHAT IF PEOPLE
WERE ABLE TO GO TO A BOTANICAL
GARDEN OR ZOO OR MISSED MUSEUM
SCULPTURE GARDEN THAT WAS
ALREADY. ALREADY PROVED TO BE
OPEN AND WHAT IF WHEN THEY GOT
THERE THERE WAS A STRING
QUARTET PLAYING OR A SERIES OF
DANCE SOLOIST PERFORMING OR
MAYBE A MAGICIAN DAZZLING
EVERYONE WITH SLEIGHT OF HAND.
SMALL SMALL PERFORMANCES FOR
SMALL NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WAS THE
WAY TO START I THOUGHT. THIS
WOULD BE A WAY FOR PEOPLE TO
LEARN HOW TO GATHER SAFELY ALL
SPREAD OUT WEARING MASKS
OUTSIDE AND THIS WOULD BE A WAY
FOR PRODUCERS AND ARTISTS TO
LEARN TOGETHER HOW TO PRODUCE
AND PERFORM SAFELY IN A
PANDEMIC. THE BIG PRODUCTION
HOUSES MIGHT NOT BE INTERESTED
RIGHT AWAY BUT THE VAST NETWORK
OF SMALL ORDS ORGANIZATIONS
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE WOULDN'T HESITATE. AND
WOULDN'T THAT START DISTILLER
CAN. AND IT. WITH DOCTOR
FOREVER G. ARE RESTORE OF THE
LA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
I MENTIONED THAT I WAS WORKING
WITH REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
THEATRICAL LABOR UNIONS TO
DEVELOP A STRATEGY FOR
INCREMENTAL RETURNED TO LIVE
PERFORMANCE. THEY WERE
INTRIGUED THEY HAD JUST
RECENTLY RECEIVED THE WHITE
PAPER FROM THE FILM TELEVISION
AND MUSIC INDUSTRIES. THAT WAS
ALSO A JOINT EFFORT OF
MANAGEMENT LABOR BY THE WAY AND
IT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL NOT ONLY
IN PROVIDING A ROAD MAP TO RE
OPEN THE SECTOR. BUT ALSO IN
KEEPING LARGE NUMBERS OF
WORKING ARTISTS HEALTHY. THE
ONLY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ENCOURAGED US TO PUT
SOMETHING SIMILAR TOGETHER FOR
THE PERFORMING ARTS. AND OUR
DEBT TASK FORCE DECIDED TO TAKE
THIS CHALLENGE ON. THIS
AFTERNOON WE WILL BE SHARING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION THE
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY OF OUR
PRINCIPLES AND RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR INCREMENTAL RETURNED TO
LIVE PERFORMANCE. WE HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SAFETY
PROTOCOLS TO SUPPORT LIVE
PERFORMANCE EVERY TIER LEVEL
STARTING WITH WORK OUTDOORS AT
DRIVE INS AND IMPARTNER VENUES.
THEN ADDING MORE INDOORS- TO
FILLMORE STREET LIVE
PERFORMANCES WITH NO AUDIENCE
PRESENT UNTIL WE ULTIMATELY
ARRIVE AT WORK IN LARGER AND
MORE TRADITIONAL PERFORMANCE
SPACES BOTH INDOORS AND
OUTDOORS. ALWAYS MAINTAINING
ROBUST PHYSICAL DISTANCING BOTH
ONSTAGE AND IN THE HOUSE.
THOUGHTFULLY LIMITING TOTAL
OCCUPANCY REQUIRING FREQUENT
PCR TESTING FOR OUR PERFORMERS
AND PRODUCTION STAFF.
ENCOURAGING MASK WEARING.
SANITATION DISK DISINFECTION
PAYING SPECIAL ATTENTION TO
VENTILATION AND ALL INDOOR
SPACES. AND INSISTING THAT
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY BE
TAKEN FOR HYGIENE AN OFFSITE
BEHAVIOR BY EVERYONE ON THE
PRODUCTION TEAM. OUR ENTIRE SET
OF RECOMMENDATION RUNS TO ABOUT
SEVENTY PAGES BUT THE EXECUTIVE
SUMMARY. PROVIDES A MUCH
SHORTER AND REASONABLY
COMPREHENSIVE OVERVIEW AND I
REALLY HOPE YOU WILL READ IT.
PERFORMING ARTS PRODUCERS KNOW
HOW TO MANAGE AUDIENCES. AND WE
AND WE IN THE THEATER HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF DEALING WITH
COMPLICATED SAFETY PROTOCOLS.
RETURNING ARTISTS AND PATRONS
TO LIVE PERFORMANCE. IN A
MANNER THAT FEELS REAL SURE WE
SAFE AND BRINGS EVERY JOY AND-
RESULT. WE CAN THAT. WE NEED
YOUR HELP NOW IN ENCOURAGING
THIS ADMINISTRATION TO ISSUE
MORE DETAILED GUIDELINES FOR
SAFE THE OPENING OF THE
PERFORMING ARTS. IDEALLY THE
AYE ADMINISTRATION WILL LIKE TO
WORK WITH OUR JOINT LABOR LABOR
MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE WE'VE
INVESTED MONTHS OF TIME IN
COLLECTIVE EFFORT INTO DELAYED
THIRTY SEVEN WE BELIEVE. IS
NEEDED AND IN ADDITION I
ENCOURAGE THIS COUNCIL TO LOOK
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OUR
SMALL AND MID SIZED
ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE ANY
RETURNED TO LIVE PERFORMANCE
SAFELY IS GOING TO BRING
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL COST
THEIR ORGANIZATIONS CANNOT
ABSORB ESPECIALLY WITH THE COST
OF COMPLIANCE WITH EIGHTY FIVE
AND THE IMPACT OF BEING. CLOSE
FOR GOING ON ELEVEN MONTHS WE
NEED SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
RELIEF OTHERWISE I'M AFRAID
THAT MANY OF OUR VIBRANT SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AT RISK OF
NEVER COMING BACK AND THAT WILL
DEAL WITH TERRIBLE BLOW TO THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND TO ALL
OF OUR IMPORTANT TO OUR OUR OUR
ALL IMPORTANT ENTERTAINMENT.
THAT WE MAY NEVER RECOVER FROM
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU JOANNE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT ROADMAP TO
OPENING. SMALL SMALL SMALL I
LIKE THAT I THINK AGAIN.
OPENING THE SMALL. OPENING
QUICKLY WITH ALL THE PROTOCOLS
YOU SUGGEST AND I AM HOPING
THAT OTHERS ON OUR CALL. I WILL.
STILL EACH OTHER'S INFORMATION
AS IF YOU SPENT THE TIME
WORKING ON IT- WE DON'T HAVE TO
REINVENT BECAUSE YOU DID A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE. ROAD MAP RIGHT
HERE THAT I JUST HEARD THANK
YOU WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY MARTHA I WAS CALLING
YOU JOANNE. SORRY MARTHA. I
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU FOR THAT
EXCELLENT PRESENTATION NEXT WE
HAVE JOHN FORSYTE REVIVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET MORE
THAN A FEW TIMES- AS HE WORKS
TIRELESSLY AND FULLER TEND NOT
FULLER CHEN SORRY ORANGE
COUNTY- BUT HE IS THE PRESIDENT
AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE PACIFIC SYMPHONY OF ORANGE
COUNTY. WELCOME JOHN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- WE WERE FOUNDED IN
FULLERTON SO I TAKE THAT AS A
COMPLIMENT. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR OFFERING
THIS HEARING TODAY AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL SPEAKERS
WHO SPOKE BEAUTIFULLY
COMPELLINGLY AND I'LL TRY TO
BUILD ANTONIANS COMMENTS SHE
DID A TERRIFIC JOB- SO.
SPECIFICALLY I YOU KNOW I RUN
AN ORCHESTRA THAT'S- ABOUT-
FORTY YEARS OLD AND I'VE BEEN
WITH IT TWENTY TWO YEARS AND
ARE MUSIC DIRECTORS BEEN WITH
ORCHESTRA THIRTY ONE YEARS AND
HE IS A DISTINGUISHED AMERICAN
LEADER HAS OFTEN SAID USYK IS A
BIRTHRIGHT THAT MUST BE SHARED
EQUALLY BY ALL. OF HIS
PHILOSOPHY IS EMBEDDED IN OUR
DNA. AND YOU'D BE SURPRISED TO
KNOW THAT 40% OF ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHOHEAR THE
PACIFIC SYMPHONY DO SO FOR FREE-
JUST BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE
RECEIVED A BEAUTIFUL TOUCHING
LETTER FROM- COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATES DESCRIBING
THE REACTION OF ONE OF THE
CHILDREN WHO ATTENDED THE
CONCERT. THE LETTER SAID MY
CLASSIC IT WAS JUST IN COMPLETE
AND UTTER AWE. SHE KEPT SAYING
ALL NIGHT LONG HOW MUCH FUN SHE
WAS HAVING OUR YOUNG GUYS COULD
NOT ABSORB ENOUGH. I DON'T KNOW
IF SHE EVEN BLANKS. DURING THE
PANDEMIC I'M PROUD TO REPORT
THAT WE CONTINUE TO PAY OUR
MUSICIANS AND THEIR FLEXIBILITY
PROVIDING DIGITAL SERVICES TO
ALL OUR PARTNERS AND AUDIENCES.
IT IS HOWEVER EXCEPTIONALLY
DIFFICULT TO SUSTAIN ITSELF FOR.
ON BEHALF OF THE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY ORCHESTRAS AND THOUSANDS
OF MUSICIANS STAFF AND BOARD
MEMBERS OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
SYMPHONY- CALIFORNIA SYMPHONY
NETWORK I URGE YOU TO ESTABLISH
GUIDELINES FOR THE SAFE RETURN
OF THE PUBLIC TO OUR
PERFORMANCE. WE ARE BEHIND
OTHER STATES IN CREATING CLEAR
RELEVANT GUIDELINES THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE. TO THOSE- SO THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE IMPACT TO THOSE IN.
THAT WE CARE ABOUT LIKE OUR
MUSICIANS AUDIENCES STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS JOHN CAN I AND
MAYBE CERTAIN JOHN CAN I. CAN
YOU JUST TELL ME EXACTLY WHAT
YOU TOLD ME THREE FOUR WHICH IS.
BY TOMORROW OR IN A MONTH OF
WHAT YOU NEED BY GUIDELINES SO
THAT YOU CAN BE PREPARED TO AT
LEAST OFFER A FOR A FULL.
SEASON IF YOU WANT TO SAY IT
THAT WAY WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN NOW
SURE. WELL LET ME JUST COMMENT
ON THE GERMAN STUDY THAT CAME
OUT WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR YOU
ALL TO UNDERSTAND GERMAN
SCIENTISTS DEMONSTRATED THAT
CONCERT HALLS CAN OPERATE AT
50% CAPACITY WITH ALMOST NO
RISK OF INFECTION. FROM COBA
NINETEEN THE STUDY SHOWS THAT A
CHECKERBOARD PATTERN OF SEATING
IN THE AUDITORIUM IT WOULD BE
ENOUGH TO ENSURE AUDIENCE
SAFETY. THIS AND OTHER STUDIES
SHOW THAT WE CAN SAFELY REOPEN
AUDIENCES NOW. SO WHILE WE READ
THE MOVIE THEATERS ARE BEING
ALLOWED TO OPEN CERTAIN TEARS A
CONCERT HALL SHOULD NOT BE
BOUND BY THE SAME REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK. AS A MOVIE THEATER
GIVEN THE CUBIC VOLUME OF AIR
AND SOPHISTICATION OF ERROR
HANNAH MOTHER AMONG OTHER
ATTRIBUTES. WITH AN ELITE
SCIENTIFIC TEAM IN GERMANY
MAKING THIS REPORT. WE HAVE TO
REPLICATE THE SAME STUDY IN OUR
CONCERT HALLS AND WE MOVE
FORWARD. SO HARPER ROAD MAP IS
BASED ON A TIERED STRUCTURE WE
EMPLOY IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
PURPLE TEAR WE RECOMMEND
OUTDOOR PERFORMANCES ALIGNED
WITH THOSE FOR LEGISLATORS SOME
PERFORMANCES. OF PERFORMANCE
ACTIVITIES WOULD BE LIMITED TO
ONE HUNDRED PATRONS IN
ATTENDANCE. ENSEMBLES WOULD
MAINTAIN SOCIAL DISTANCE DOES
DISTANCING BUT FORECASTERS
COULD PERFORM IN THE LARGE
STAGE ACCOMMODATES AGREED UPON
RECORDING INDUSTRY FOR LABOR
MANAGEMENT SAFETY AGREEMENTS.
INDOORS NO MORE THAN FIFTY
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO ATTEND. THE
RED TIER OUTDOOR PERFORMANCES
WOULD INCREASE TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY NO MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
PERMITTED INDOORS. HOWEVER IT
IS IN THE ORANGE TEAR THAT WE
PROPOSE UTILIZING THE CHECKER
BOARD SEATING PLAN FOR INDOOR
AND OUTDOOR VENUES. AND IT IS
WHAT THE YELLOW TIER AND THIS
IS WHERE I THINK WE REALLY NEED
YOUR ASSISTANCE WE WOULD ASK
YOU TO CONSIDER ALLOWING FULL
RE OPENING. OF OUR OUTDOOR
CONCERT HALL AND INDOOR CONCERT
VENUES. WITH MASKING SPACING
FOR PUBLIC AREAS CLEANING AND
OTHER CDC SAFETY PROTOCOL.
PLEASE BEAR IN MIND IS DE TO
MAKE IMMEDIATE CHANGES GIVEN
THE LONG LEAD TIMES WE REQUIRE
SO PROVIDE SOME BUFFER TIME TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SERVE
TRACKS. GIVEN THE VARIABILITY
OF PHYSICAL SIZE OF PERFORMANCE
AND SEATING AREAS BOTH OUTDOORS
AND INDOORS. THE SOPHISTICATION
OF AIR HANDLING AND OTHER
VARIABLES WE WOULD ASK THAT OUR
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS IMPACT
OUR TO REVIEW A SAFETY PLAN
WITH A LOT LESS THAN SEVEN DAYS
NOTICE. THAT MIGHT ALLOW FOR
ORGANIZATION TO EXCEED CAPACITY
THRESHOLD PARTICULARLY IN THE
EARLY STAGES. WE ALSO ASK FOR
CLEAR GUIDANCE ON THE POINT AT
WHICH FULL SEATING CAPACITY
WITH MASKS FOR WITHOUT. IS
PERMISSIBLE RECOGNIZED THINGS
ARE VERY ONG PLANNING LEAD
TIMES. AT THREE FINAL POINTS I
WOULD VISIT THE- DURING THE
PANDEMIC PURPOSES OF
SUCCESSFULLY MAKING THE CASE
FOR PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT THE
CRIPPLING LOSS OF TICKET SALES
I'M NOT BEING ABLE TO HOLD IN
PERSON PERFORMANCES MEAN WE
NEED A FINANCIAL INFORMATION
FROM THE STATE. TO GET BACK ON
OUR FEET PARTICULARLY AFTER A
FEDERAL PROGRAMS WAIT. IT WILL
TAKE TIME TO REGAIN AUDIENCES
AND RESTORE REVENUE. AND SECOND
AS EARLIER STATED OUR MUSICIANS
ARE TEACHING ARTISTS WORKING AS
TEACHING ARTISTS IN PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE. A
CATEGORIZATION ALONGSIDE
TEACHERS AND WAS SEEN IN THE
BACKSEAT. AND LASTLY. I WOULD
JUST SAY- IN RELATION TO THE
ARTS COUNCIL FUNDING I WANT TO
RE EMPHASIZE WE ARE ONE TEN THE
FUNDING LEVEL OF THE STATE OF
MINNESOTA. IT IS TIME TO REALLY
MAKE CALIFORNIA LEADER NOT A
LAGGARD WE NEED TO GET AHEAD
AND WE NEED. TO BE THE STATE
LEADS THE WAY IN THE RE OPENING
OF THE ARTS AND CULTURE. OKAY
THERE IS A QUOTE THAT WE CAN
USE WE WANT TO BE A LEADER NOT
A LAGGARD AT IN NOT ONLY ARE
ARTS FUNDING BUT AND IT'S
STARTING TO OPEN UP THE- VENUES
AS WE KNOW WE ARE A LANGER
RIGHT NOW- THAT BEING SAID-
GUIDELINES AGAIN IN ORDER TO
GET SOME OF THIS RE OPENING SO-
I APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU DO.
JOHN AND- WE ARE HOPEFULLY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
BE THE BROKEN RECORD TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
FOR THEM. JOINING US. MEDICARE
THIS IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
SO I AM I'M ALSO GOING TO HAVE
TO STEP OUT FOR THIS- CAUCUS
BUT I JUST WANTED TO SHARE
SOMETHING THAT I'D BEEN AND
TALKING ABOUT GUIDELINES THAT
I'VE BEEN TAKING NOTES ON AND
WHAT I'VE ALSO HEARD IS YOU
KNOW I MADE YOU STRONGER
DISCUSSION WITH EDT ON HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE-
SPECIALIZED CARE FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE IN THE CREATIVE ECONOMY WE
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE VERY
CHALLENGING TIMES IS GETTING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE OUT
REGULARLY BUT EVEN IN THE PAST
THEY HAVE STRUGGLED WITH MAKING
SURE THAT ARTISTS. WERE ABLE TO
GET THEIR CLAIMS BECAUSE
THEY'RE CONSIDERED SEASONAL
WORKERS SO I'D LIKE TO ADD THAT
TO WHAT WE'RE PUTTING IN THE
RECORD DIGITAL BROADBAND CAME
UP. FROM OUR SISTER IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF
SMALL NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
ARE CHALLENGED WITH THAT ACCESO
AS WORTH FIGHTING FOR DIGITAL
BROADBAND ACCESS FOR ALL WE
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT WERE
INCORPORATING THE ARTS INTO
THAT. IN JUST BE TRUE ARTS
RECOVERY INFUSION OF DOLLARS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
RED LEAD FOR MORE TALKING ABOUT
CHILD CARE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HEALTHCARE- YOU KNOW MANY OF
OUR ARTISTS ARE WORKING TO
THREE FOR JOBS- AND SO HOW DO
WE SORT OF FORMALIZED SOMETHING
THAT'S TARGETED. YOU KNOW IT'S
ALSO SOMETHING THAT I'VE HEARD
AND THE YOU KNOW LASTLY THERE
WAS ALSO A STUDY THAT CAME OUT.
THAT SAID EVEN 20% CAPACITY.
WOULD WORK- FOR MANY- ARTS
INSTITUTIONS AND EVEN OTHER
SMALL BUSINESSES SO. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M
PUTTING THAT IN THE RECORD OF
WAYS THAT WE CAN WORK
AGGRESSIVELY TO SUPPORT OUR
ARTS COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOMEOWNER AND I
AGREED THOSE. NOTES WILL BE
ADDED AND ALL EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND AGAIN THIS IS WHY
WE DO THESE. INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. WE HEAR SOME
INFORMATION REGULARLY BUT THEN
THERE'S NEW INFORMATION AND
THAT THE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE JUST BEEN SAID BY OUR
PANELISTS THAT MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN ON THE TOP. OF OUR LIST SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND THANK
YOU WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND MOVE NOW TO DAN BECKERMAN
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. OF AB E. G. WORLDWIDE.
WELCOME DAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF NOT ONLY A
U. G. ABOUT ON THE SPORTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC FOR US IN ALL
THE AREAS BEING DISCUSSED
TODAY. WE SEE THEM AS PART OF
THE SAME ECOSYSTEM THE ARTS
MUSIC ENTERTAINMENT AND
TOURISM- TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
CONTEXT E. G. WORLDWIDE SPORTS
AND ENTERTAINMENT COMPANY WERE
HEADQUARTERED IN LOS ANGELES.
AND WHILE WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
PROPERTIES ALL OVER THE WORLD-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
OWN AND OPERATE TWO STADIUMS
SIX SPORTS TEAMS INCLUDING THE
LA KINGS SEVEN CONVENTION
CENTERS INCLUDING- MOSCONI AND
THE LA CONVENTION CENTER. EIGHT
ARENAS INCLUDING STAPLES CENTER
TEN MUSIC FESTIVALS INCLUDING
THE COACHELLA FESTIVAL AND
FIFTEEN CLUBS AND THEATRES UP
AND DOWN THE COAST SO WE'RE OF
A MAJOR STAKEHOLDER IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU'VE HEARD
SEVERAL TIMES TODAY ALREADY
LIVE ENTERTAINMENT WAS THE
FIRST INDUSTRY TO BE SHUT DOWN
AND WILL BE THE LAST TO RETURN
AND OVER THE COURSE OF OUR SHUT
DOWN IT WILL WILL LOSE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
REVENUES THAT WOULD HAVE
GENERATED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. IN INCOME SALES
BUSINESS AND OTHER TAXES FOR
THE CITY THE COUNTY AND STATE-
IN ADDITION TO THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT OF THE ONE THAT WEIGHS
HEAVY ON US IS THE IMPACT THAT
THIS HAS HAD. ON OUR EMPLOYEES
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA. I HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED WITH
FURLOUGHS AND LAYOFFS. AND TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PART TIME EVENT
EMPLOYEES WHO SHE IS. THE SHIPS
HAVE JUST DISAPPEARED AS THESE
EVENTS HAVE BEEN CANCELED.
THESE ARE OUR SECURITY OFFICERS
ARE USHERS ARE CUSTODIAL STAFF
OR CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. AND
MANY OF THEM RELY ON THOSE
SHIPS AS THEIR PRIMARY SOURCE
OF INCOME. OTHERS JUST NEED
THOSE SHIFTS TO MAKE ENDS MEET-
BUT EITHER WAY THESE ARE LONG
STANDING IT IMPLODING IS- I
WANNA MAKE A POINT I THINK I'M
THE ONLY ONE SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE SPORTS BUSINESS
SO I LIKE TO JUST. HIGHLIGHT
ONE POINT ON SPORTS TOURISM-
AND THE SPORTS RELATED TRAVEL
INDUSTRY IT'S A MASSIVE.
INDUSTRY FORTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS OF ANNUAL SPENDING.
THREE QUARTERS OF A MILLION
JOBS FIFTEEN BILLION IN TAX
REVENUE NATIONALLY. AND THIS
SECTOR HAS JUST BEEN
DEVASTATED- AS EVENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CANCELED OR
RELOCATED- WERE CONDUCTED
WITHOUT FANS- YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM OUR OUR FRIENDS AND OUR
PARTNERS AT LIVE NATION- IN A
SECOND AND I WHAT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT. IT'S NOT
JUST LARGE COMPANIES LIKE LIVE
NATION AND AEG THAT ARE HAVING-
OUR REVENUES AND OUR EMPLOYEES
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. THERE
ARE COUNTLESS SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THIS
CRISIS AS WELL IT COULD BE THE
FAMILY OWNED RESTAURANT ACROSS
THE STREET FROM STAPLES CENTER
THAT NEEDS ARE PUT TRAFFIC. OR
ONE OF THE MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE VENDORS OR
SUPPLIERS TO OUR RESTAURANTS
ARE FESTIVALS IN OUR BAND. IT
COULD BE THE WOMAN KNOWN CUSTOM
SIGNAGE COMPANY OR THE MINORITY
OWN PARTY TO COURT COMPANY THAT
WE WORK WITH L. A. LOT. BUT
THIS CRISIS HAS REALLY TAKEN
ITS TOLL ON FAMILY MINORITY AND
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES THAT
RELY ON SPORTS ENTERTAINMENT
AND TOURISM. I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
GUIDELINES I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT FOR A QUICK SECOND- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNMENT AND WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND IS TASK
FORCE OVER THE LAST TEN MONTHS-
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
SOME PROGRESS AND WE'VE
DEVELOPED THE GUIDELINES AND
PROCEDURES FOR. HOW WE CAN
SAFELY LIVE WITH THAT CODE
NINETEEN BUYERS AND OPERATE
PARTS OF OUR BUSINESS IS IN A
LIMITED WAY. WE HAVE FAMILIES
GUIDELINES WE HAVE PARTIAL
CAPACITY GUIDELINES AND WE
PRIORITIZE THE SAFETY OF OUR
EMPLOYEES OUR ATHLETES ARE
ARTISTS AND. ART FANS AS OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY. AND WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO THAT AND WE
CREATED A SAFETY. WE POSTED
FAMILIES. OVER THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS. BUT IT IS NOT ENOUGH
THE LAST SPEAKER- PUT IT VERY
VERY WELL IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO
RESTORE INDUSTRY. AND BRING
BACK OUR EMPLOYEES- ALL WRAPPED
UP HERE IN A SECOND BUT AYE
AYE. I WANNA IT SHOWS SOME
OPTIMISM BECAUSE THANKFULLY
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE CHANGING. SEX
SCENES ARE GOING INTO ARMS FOR
A MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION.
WE'RE SEEING THE CASE COUNTS
FINALLY COME DOWN IN THE PATH
RATES DECLINING WHICH IS
ENCOURAGING. NOW WE HAVE THIS
UNIQUE LINES THAT WE OPERATE
VENUES ALL OVER THE WORLD SO WE
CAN SEE. THAT WITH PROPER
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND MANDATORY
MASK WEARING AND REGULAR
TESTING OF OUR STAFF. WE CAN
SAFELY HOST EVENTS ITH PARTIAL
CAPACITY. AND WE SEE IT IN
CHINA WE SEE IT IN OUR VENUES
IN AUSTRALIA AND NEW ZEALAND.
AND WE CAN SEE A PATH TO
RETURNING OUR BUSINESS- AND THE
TRANSITION TO STARTED HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES AS WELL. BUT
AS AN INDUSTRY OUR PRIMARY
FOCUS NEEDS TO BE EVOLVING THE
GUIDELINES WE HAVE TODAY. TO
REFLECT THE FACT THAT
VACCINATIONS ARE GOING INTO
ARMS. AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE STATE AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS AND OUR HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. TO TAKE THOSE
GUIDELINES ENHANCE THEM AND
ADAPT THEM FROM WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY. WHICH IS REALLY FOCUSED
ON HOW WE LIVE WITH THE VIRUS.
TO A SYSTEM THAT WILL HELP US
EMERGE FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
BEGIN TO LIVE WITHOUT. THANK
YOU VERY MCH. THANK YOU AND- I
THINK THIS REALLY DOES HELP ME
PUT INTO PERSPECTIVE- FROM VERY
LARGE ENTERTAINMENT
ORGANIZATION LIKE YOURS BUT TO
THE SMALLER ONES OF HOW WE CAN
TAKE THE SCENARIO WE'RE IN
RIGHT NOW AS YOU MENTIONED
WITH. VACCINES AS ACCOUNTS
GOING DOWN AND EVEN DEATH ON
START TO REALLY LOOK AT WHAT IS
OUR NEXT SIX MONTH PLAN. WE
WILL THAT NOW MOVED TO JAIL
BURKE I TOLD THE WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT OF LIVE NATION.
WELCOME JAIL. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
YEAR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY. MY NAME IS JOE BURKE
TOLD I'M THE PRESIDENT OF LIVE
NATION ENTERTAINMENT- WHERE
THEY WANT TO BE GLOBAL LEADERS
IN LIVE ENTERTAINMENT WE
OPERATE IN. FORTY COUNTRIES
WITH OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
pMORE THAN FIFTY THOUSAND AROUND
THE WORLD. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE PROMOTED FORTY
THOUSAND CONCERTS AND HUNDRED
FESTIVALS FOR A HUNDRED MILLION
FANS GLOBALLY. WE ARE BASED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE OUR
HEADQUARTERS IN LOS ANGELES. WE
EMPLOY OVER SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA DURING
THE SUMMER CONCERT SEASON. AB
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE
APPROXIMATE FOUR THOUSAND SHOWS
AND SEVEN MILLION FANS. ATTEND
AT OVER THIRTY VENUES IN THE
STATE- THIS IS FANTA SPOKE TO
MANY OF THE REOPENING PLANS
LAST FAR HAVE BEEN. FOCUSED
AROUND SOCIAL DISTANCE TEAM
LIMITED CAPACITY AND OTHER
NECESSARY SAFEGUARDS OF MINE.
BEFORE THE VACCINES WERE
AVAILABLE. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
HAS A MAP THERE ARE SEVERELY
CONSTRAINED- ONE NATION OVER
THE PAST YEARS LOST MORE THAN
95% OF ITS REVENUE. BUT MORE
BROADLY 77% ALIVE INDUSTRY
WORKERS OF LOS THE 100% OF
THEIR INCOME. ALLISON'S OF
WORKERS THAT AREN'T ANY
IMPACTED BY THE FURLOUGHS AND
LAYOFFS HAVE HAD TREMENDOUS
DAMAGE AS MANY OF THE SPEAKERS
AND SPOKEN TO. RESERVISTS
OFFICE STATUS LOST MILLIONS IN
TAX REVENUE AND MUCH MORE AN
OVERALL ECONOMIC IMPACT. BUT
NOW IS WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
THE LIGHT AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL WITH AXIOM ROLLOUT. WE
DO THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
TURN THE FOCUS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENS. WHEN THE VACCINE
IS READILY AVAILABLE. THE GOOD
NEWS CAN WITH TRACK ON ON BACKS.
ACTUALLY CURRENTLY INDICATE
SHOULD BE A ACT MAXINE FOR
EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY BY.
AND AT THAT POINT WHAT ARE OUR
PLANS NOW FIRST WE UNDERSTAND
THE PRIORITY NEEDS TO BE ON THE
DISTRIBUTION OF ALL AVAILABLE
SUPPLY TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
POSSIBLES VACCINATED. IN THIS
PART IN STAFFORD MY NATION'S
DRAWING WITH AG LEAVE- I OUT
SEE ANOTHER'S REPRESENTED IN
THIS HEARING OFFER OUR
FACILITIES AND RESOURCES TO THE
VACCINATION EFFORT. WE'VE
POSTED VENUES IN ACTIVE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND HAPPINESS
MAXINE SITES AND WE'RE PREPARED
TO HELP ANY EFFORTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE CAN'T. THEN
AS WE CONTINUE TO GET FURTHER
CLARITY ON VACCINES TIMING IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ESTABLISH NOW THE
GUIDELINES FOR RE OPENING WHEN
THOSE VACCINES ARE AVAILABLE TO
ALL. WE NEED THOSE FACTS THE
THOSE GUIDELINES NOW BECAUSE
THE LEAD TIME PROMOTERS ARE
STILL PLANNED ITS WORST SELL
THE TICKETS REHEARSED THE SHALL
REMAIN PERFORMED. EVERYONE
NEEDS OF THE COMPLIMENTS OF
SHOWS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HAPPEN IF THE GUIDELINES ARE
MET IN ORDER TO GET STARTED. AS
PART OF THIS WE NEED CLARITY ON
HOW THESE. GUIDELINES WILL VARY
FOR OUTDOOR VENUES. WHICH HAVE
DEMONSTRATED MUCH GREATER LOWER
RISK OF TRANSMISSION. IT
REMAINS DAR AMBITION TO RETURN
MONNING CONCERTS AT SCALE THIS
SUMMER BUT ACCOMPLISHING THIS
REQUIRES GUIDELINES THAT WE THE
ARTISTS AND FANS ALIKE CAN
DEPEND ON. WE STAND READY TO DO
OUR PART OF THE RE OPENING
PROVIDING ENHANCED CLEANING
SANITATION CONTACT WITH
CENTURY- CONTACTLESS PAYMENTS.
STAGGER CROWD FLOW IN A RANGE
OF OTHER OPERATIONAL
PRECAUTIONS AS WE'D BE IN THE
WELL BEING OF FANS ARTISTS AND
STAFF WILL ALWAYS BE OUR TOP
PRIORITY. WE ALSO NOT OF THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT TOGETHER
WORKING FOR USING OTHERS AND
DEVASTATING AND WITH THE
VACCINE PROCESS UNDER WAY IT'S
CRITICAL TO NOW TURN OUR
ATTENTION. FOR THEIR FUTURE
WELL BEING THEIR FUTURE
FINANCIAL WELL BEING AS WELL.
THANKFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR PERSPECTIVE WITH THE
COMMITTEE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION SO
WE MAY SEE A RETURN TO LIVE
MUSIC. AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU JOE A
VIRTUAL VIRTUAL THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF LIVE NATION. AND
BETWEEN DAN BECKERMAN AND JOE
BIRCH TOLD WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF JOBS
AND BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. THAT HAS IMPACTED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WITH
THIS IS A SERIOUS SERIOUS
DISCUSSION. AND THERE IS NO
DISAGREEMENT OF RE OPENING
SAFELY BUT MANY OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS THAT IS THEIR JOB
TO MOVE PEOPLE MOVE THEM SAFELY
THREE THROUGH AND THE LAST
THING THEY WANT IS SOME TYPE OF
SUPER SPREADER EVENT. WITH THAT
THE- I KNOW WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN THAT
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AT
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO TAKE OFF IN A COUPLE
OF MINUTES JUST WANTED TO RE
EMPHASIZE SOMETHING I'M GLAD
THAT EVERYONE. HAS TOUCHED ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
GUIDELINES- I GUESS I JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE TO ALL THE
PANELISTS AS WELL AS TO
OURSELVES HERE THAT IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE LOOK AT THE
GUIDELINES. FOR ALL LEVELS OF
THE ARTS AND MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE FROM THE AGES OF THE
WORLD AND LIVE NATIONS OF THE
WORLD. DOWN TO THE NINETY NINE
INDIVIDUAL THEATERS ARE ALL
WITHIN THE GUIDELINE CATEGORIES
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHERE IS THE
ECONOMIC BOOM ENGINES AND THE
BOOST OF TODAY ARE THE LIVE
NATION'S AND THE AGES OF THE
WORLD. THE HUMAN LABORATORIES
OF THE NINETY NINE SEAT
THEATERS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE PRODUCING THE
TALENT FOR TOMORROW. SO WE GOT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE-
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS AT EVERY
LEVEL. OF THE ARTS I JUST
WANTED TO RE EMPHASIZE THAT
POINT BECAUSE I HAD MISSED THAT
INITIALLY. ARE FROM THE
GONZALES SR LARGEST- WHETHER
THEIR THEATERS OR- AT DURING
COMPANIES WE NEED TO ADDRESS
ALL BECAUSE- SINCE I HAVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE WHAT I HAVE
HEARD FIRST HAND. IT'S THE
UNCERTAINTY OF NOT KNOWING AND
AGAIN WE'RE ALL. WORKING
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND MANY
IT NONE OF US HAVE BEEN THROUGH
A PANDEMIC SO THIS IS NOT TO
PUT A BLAME GAME. BUT IT
CERTAINLY TO SAY WE DON'T WANT
US TO SEE OTHER STATES- TAKING
OUR ACTORS IN THEATERS IN OUR
MOVIE COMPANIES WE WANT TO KEEP
BUSINESS HERE BUT WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE THE VERY BASIC
INFORMATION TO. AT THESE
INSTITUTIONS AND THAT THAT IS
THE MOST UPDATED GUIDELINES AND
A ROADMAP TO RECOVERY- IDC THAT
ARE VICE CHAIR- SUZETTE.
MARTINEZ SLOW THERE AS WE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. FIRST OF ALL
JUST WANT TO THANK ALL OF THEM
THE PANELISTS AND PARTICIPANTS
TODAY FOR SHARING YOUR STORIES
AND YOUR ON THE GROUND AND
WITHOUT YOUR INPUT AND INSIGHT
AS TO HOW. YOU HAVE BEEN
INDIVIDUALLY IMPACTED IT WOULD
MAKE OUR JOB A LOT HARDER WE
RELY ON YOUR COMMENT AND OTHER
THAN THE TWO WORDS- YOU'RE ON
MUTE. THE WORD OF THE YEAR IS
DEFINITELY GONNA BE GUIDELINES
AND HOW WE CAN START TO FRAME
ON WHAT THOSE GUIDELINES WORK
LOOK LIKE I WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU TO REACH OUT TO YOUR
LEGISLATORS TO ME- TO THE CHORE
WHEN DR WOMAN'S OFFICE WITH
YOUR IDEAS AND- AND NOT TO
FORGET THE OTHER STATES YOU
KNOW OTHER COUNTRIES. ARE MORE
OPEN AND WE ARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT EVIDENCE CAN WE FIND WHAT
DEMOCRATIC CAN WE FIND AND USE
THAT SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL AND EVERY
ASPECT HERE. AND I ALSO WANT TO
DISPOSE ON THIS QUESTION OF-
CAPACITY AND HOW CAPACITY- FOR
EACH OF THE VENUES IN EACH OF
THE EACH OF THE INDUSTRIES THAT
HAVE BEEN- SO IMPACTED HOW
CAPACITY. IS TIED TO THEIR
SUSTAINABILITY ESPECIALLY WHAT
ARE SMALLER THAN SO I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR TIME. AND
WEEK WE HEAR YOU ON LOOK
FORWARD TO. THIS CON. THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE FOR MORE
PRESENTERS AND THEY ARE.
DEFINITELY THE LAST BUT THEY'RE
CERTAINLY NOT THE SO WE WILL
MOVE. TO RUTH CARLTON WHO IS.
THE DIRECTOR OF FESTIVAL VENUE
OPERATIONS ANOTHER PLANET
ENTERTAINMENT. WELCOME RUTH-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CASEY
LOUDERMILK WHO'S THE NEXT
PERSON IS GOING TO GO IN ME IN
THIS. HELLO AND CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WELL MMHM
AND YES HE MENTIONED CASEY A
LOAN LOAN AMOUNT WITH ASSISTANT
MANAGER AT BILL GRAHAM CIVIC.
AUDITORIUM WILL BE- PART OF THE
PRESENTATION AS WELL. HI YEP
THANK YOU TO HELLO TO SOAK INTO
SHARE THIS SLIDESHOW. THERE WE
GO YEAH. ALL RIGHT AND I ARE
HERE FROM ANOTHER PLANET
ENTERTAINMENT WE ARE THE
LARGEST INDEPENDENT CONCERT
PROMOTER IN CALIFORNIA WE
PERCENT OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
SHOWS A YEAR HOSTING OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION LIVE MUSIC.
ARBENZ RANGE FROM FIVE HUNDRED
TO PASS A BIG BLOW TO A TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
PERSON THREE DAY MUSIC FESTIVAL
IN GOLDEN GATE PARK.
INDEPENDENT VENUES AND CONCERT
PROMOTERS ARE ANCHOR BUSINESSES
IN YOUR COMMUNITY. ACCORDING TO
A RECENT ECONOMIC IMPACT STUDY.
FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR SPENT ON A
CONCERT TICKET WELL DOLLARS TO
GENERATE IN THE LOCAL ECONOMY
AND BARS RESTAURANTS LODGING
AND TRANSPORTATION. WHICH MEANS
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT INDEPENDENT
VENUES IN CALIFORNIA IS
ESTIMATED AT OVER THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.SINCE
THE SHUTDOWN WE'VE ALL BECOME
NEW FOUND INDUSTRY ADVOCATES
EMERGING FROM BEHIND THE
CURTAINS AND ENGAGING WITH THE
NATIONAL INDEPENDENT VENUE
ASSOCIATION OR DEVELOP. A GROUP
OF TENACIOUSLY INDEPENDENT
VENUE OWNERS FESTIVALS AND
PROMOTERS BORN IN APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY IN RESPONSE TO COVER
NINETEEN EVEN HAS OVER THREE
THOUSAND MEMBERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. YOUR FOURTH REGIONAL
COALITIONS FROM SAN DIEGO
ORANGE COUNTY LOS ANGELES AREA
SACRAMENTO. A FULL YEAR OF
ANOTHER PLANET CONCERTS HAVE
BEEN CANCELED INCLUDING OUR
MAJOR MUSIC FESTIVAL OUTSIDE
LANDS TWENTY TWENTY. IF WE
CAN'T PRODUCE OUTSIDE LANDS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT WILL BE
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN LOST REVENUE
TO THE BAY AREA ECONOMY. AND
THE EQUIVALENT OF OVER TWO
THOUSAND FULL TIME JOBS LOST IN
ADDITION TO IT BEING A MAJOR
REVENUE LOSS TO THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S GENERAL FUND. WE'RE
THE FIRST TO CLOSE LAST
REOPENING NO REVENUE AND ALL
THE OVERHEAD COSTS. TO DATE
OVER THREE HUNDRED INDEPENDENT
VENUES ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
PERMANENTLY CLOSED. IN ADDITION
95% OF WORKERS HAVE BEEN LET GO
OR FURTHER TEACH THE PANDEMIC
THIS INCLUDES NOT ONLY UNION
THEATRICAL LABOR BUT ALSO
BARTENDERS SECURITY CATERING
JANITORIAL SOUND AND LIGHTING
COMPANIES TRUCK DRIVERS AND
MANY MORE. AS NEVA WE
SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATED FOR THE
SAVE OUR STATE EXACT TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE RECENTLY
PASSCODE RELIEF PACKAGE HOWEVER
WE HAVE YET TO SEE AN
APPLICATION FOR THIS GRANT
PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM WILL BE A
MUCH NEEDED LIFELINE BUT AS
THIS HEARING MAKES APPARENT WE
HAVE YET TO SEE OUR FINISH
LINE. IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE
WILL NEED TO BE A PATCHWORK OF
RELIEF AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
WON'T BE A MASS CULTURAL
EXTINCTION IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE SEEN SMALLER MARKETS
INVESTING THE SURVIVAL OF THEIR
CREATIVE ECONOMY DURING THIS
SHUTDOWN. FOR EXAMPLE ORGAN HAS
INVESTED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
MARYLAND AT THIRTY MILLION AND
MANY MORE. THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT
RE OPENING CONCERTS AND
FESTIVALS IS THAT YOU HAVE AG
INDUSTRY A PUBLIC ASSEMBLY
SAFETY EXPERTS WHO CAN'T
SIDELINE BUT NOTHING ELSE TO DO
RESEARCH AND PREPARE FOR SAFE
REOPENING. OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS AS AN INDUSTRY WE HAVE
GONE TO GREAT LENGTHS TO
RESPOND AND ADAPT TO A GROWING
NUMBER OF THREATS ACTIVE
SHOOTERS AND THREATS OF
TERRORISM. PROMPTED THE QUICK
ADOPTION OF MAGNETOMETERS CLEAR
BAG POLICIES MULTI AGENCY
ONSITE COMMAND CENTERS AND
HOSTILE VEHICLE MITIGATION.
THESE TRAINERS REPRESENTED 25%
INCREASE OUR EXPENSES BUT
AREN'T SURE TO FIRST AND
FOREMOST TO CREATE SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS. MASK GATHERINGS
INCLEMENT WEATHER OR SAFETY
THIS IS WHAT WE AS A LOT OF
MINISTRY WORK ON A PLAN FOR WE
ARE THE BEST PREPARED TO MEET
THE CHALLENGES. OF CREATING A
COVERT SAFE OF THAT. YEAH OF
THIS INCOME. DON'T WORK IF
THEY'RE NOT FAULT SCALE. REMOVE
VENUES ARTISTS THE SENATE. HAVE
THE SAME EXPENSES WHETHER THE
ROOM IS A 20% OR A 100% SOLD
REAL BRING GUIDELINES ONLY FOR
SOCIAL A DEFINITE WILL NOT
BRING US BACK. BUSTLES IN
CONCERT THE A SUBSTANTIAL ONE
WAY TO GET OVER TO PRODUCE A
CONCERT WE NEED MONTHS OF THE
TIME AND FOR ARTISTS MARKETS
SHOWS SELL TICKETS AND HIGHER
MEMBERS AND STAFF. WE ARE
ASKING THE STATE TO GIVE US A
SEAT AT THE TABLE TO HELP
DEVELOP PLANS TO REOPEN SAFELY
AT FULL CAPACITY WHEN WE RE
OPEN WE WILL AGAIN BE A MAJOR
ECONOMIC DRIVER IF WE CAN'T
REOPEN WE NEED YOUR HELP TO
STAY ALIVE. IN THE PAST WE HAVE
SHOULDERED THE ESCALATING COSTS
TO KEEP OUR CONCERT SAFE NEVER
COMPROMISING OUR EFFORTS AND
NEVER REACHING OUT FOR HELP.
BUT THIS IS A SITUATION WE
CAN'T SEE OUR WAY THROUGH ALONE
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING
WITH YOU TO DEVELOP TARGETED
FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR SHATTERED
INDEPENDENT VENUES AND
PROMOTERS. CONCERTS BRING
DIVERSE GROUPS OF PEOPLE
TOGETHER. THIS TYPE OF UNITY IS
SOMETHING THAT IS SO NEEDED
RIGHT NOW IN OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU AND AS YOU CAN
SEE WE KIND OF HAVE THREE
PRESENTERS RELATED TO- MAJOR
CONCERTS AND ENTERTAINMENT I
CAN TELL YOU PERSONALLY THAT. I
TO MISS CONCERTS AND I KNOW
MANY OF MY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS JUST CANNOT WAIT. WE
ALSO TAKE SERIOUS- THE
VACCINATIONS THAT- ARE
HAPPENING. AND NEED TO LEAVE
THIS HEARING BY IS SENDING A
STRONG MESSAGE- THAT. WE CAN
REOPEN SAFELY AND THAT MANY OF
YOU THAT ARE ON THIS CALL ARE
IN THE BUSINESS TO DO EXACTLY
THAT. OUR LAST TWO PRESENTERS
ARE RELATED TO OUR MUSEUMS ARE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS IN LOS ANGELES. COUNTY
MUSEUM OF ART SO WE WILL
WELCOME CELESTE DAY WALDRON WHO
IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATIONS OF
MUSEUMS. WELCOME FOR LESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR INVITING ME TO
PRESENT THIS MORNING ON THE
IMPACT OF CODE NINETEEN ON
MUSEUMS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF MUSEUMS DEFINITION OF
MUSEUMS- IS A NONPROFIT AND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS. THAT
MAKE UNIQUE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
COMMUNITY BY INTERPRETING AND
PRESERVING THE THINGS OF THIS
WORLD THAT INCLUDES
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COLLECT
OBJECTS SUCH AS ART HISTORY AND
NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM BUT IT
ALSO INCLUDES NON COLLECTING
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE SCIENCE
CENTERS AND CHILDREN'S MUSEUM.
AND THOSE WOULD LIVING
COLLECTIONS LIKE AQUARIUMS ZOOS
AND BOTANICAL GARDEN. MANY
PEOPLE VISIT MUSEUMS MORE THAN
THE NUMBER WHO ATTEND
PROFESSIONAL SPORTING EVENTS.
AND MUSEUMS ARE ECONOMIC
ENGINES AND THEIR FINANCIAL
HEALTH IS IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF OUR ECONOMY. BEFORE I
UNDERSCORE THE DIRE
CONSEQUENCES OF KOBE NINETEEN
LET ME SHINE A LIGHT ON SOME OF
THE POSITIVE OUTCOMES.
PRACTICALLY PRACTICALLY
OVERNIGHT THE WAY MUSEUMS
DELIVER THEIR EDUCATIONAL
CONTENT HAS SHIFTED. IN THE
MUSEUM WASN'T ALREADY
DELIVERING TOURISM PROGRAMS
ONLINE THEY ARE NOW JUST WHEN
THE PUBLIC STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS NEED AT THE MOMENT.
YOU HEARD ABOUT SOME OF THE
WAYS MUSEUMS ARE DIRECTLY
RESPONDING TO THE CRISIS AND
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES HAS
COVERED NINETEEN TEST IN SIGHT
DISTANCE LEARNING HUB- PANTRIES
VOTING CENTERS AND NOW OFFERING
TO BE VACCINATIONS BY. BY THE
CREATIVITY THE REALITY IS THAT
MUSEUMS ARE CLOSED AND THEN IT
HAVING VERY REAL NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THEIR FINANCIAL
STABILITY AND IS CURBING THEIR
ABILITY TO FULLY SERVE THE
PUBLIC. MANY MUSEUMS HAVE RE
OPENED ACROSS THE COUNTRY BASED
ON A SURVEY IN MID OCTOBER 71%
OF MUSEUMS ACROSS THE NATION
ARE OPEN. BUT IN CALIFORNIA
INDOOR MUSEUMS ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO REOPEN A PURPLE TEAR COUNTY
WITH NINETY NINE POINT 9% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION IN A
PURPLE TEAR RIGHT NOW THE VAST
MAJORITY OF MUSEUMS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE CLOSE AND HAVE BEEN
FOR ALMOST A YEAR. ARE
ASSOCIATION AND OTHERS HAVE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR PARITY IN
THE STATE BLUEPRINT WHICH
SHOPPING MALL. THERE IS NO
PLAUSIBLE EVIDENCE BASED
EXPLANATION FOR MUSEUMS TO BE
CLOSE WHEN SHOPPING MALLS AND
EVEN FOR PROFIT ART GALLERIES
ARE OPEN. THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
EDITORIAL BOARD PROMINENT
MAYORS ACROSS THE STATE AND
TWENTY SEVEN LEGISLATORS
INCLUDING YOU MADAM CHAIR HAVE
ALL EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THIS
POSITION. MUSEUMS ARE SIMPLY
NOT THE ENVIRONMENT THAT ARE
CAUSING AN INCREASE IN
TRANSMISSION THEY ARE CAPABLE
OF OPERATING SAFELY. OUR ASIAN
ESTIMATES THAT CALIFORNIA
MUSEUMS ARE LOSING TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS A DAY DURING
STATEWIDE CLOSURES. THIS IS DUE
TO A LOSS OF ADMISSIONS STORE
STATE HEALTH EVENT RENTALS
FUNDRAISING EVENTS ANYMORE.
MUSEUMS OPERATING RESERVES ARE
DIMINISHING AND WON'T LAST MUCH
LONGER NEARLY A THIRD OF MUSEUM
DIRECTORS ARE UNSURE IF THEY'RE
MUSEUM WILL SURVIVE THE
PANDEMIC. WHAT CAN YOU AS OUR
STATE LEADERS DO TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA MUSEUM JOIN US IN
TRYING TO PERSUADE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO LET MUSEUM
THREE OPEN AT THE SAME CAPACITY
AS SHOPPING MALLS. SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED KOBE
NINETEEN RELIEF FUNDING FOR
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS BUT
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. ALLOW
NONPROFIT CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
OF ALL SIZES TO APPLY FOR
RELIEF NINETY. PRIORITIZE
ORGANIZATIONS WITH LESS ACCESS
TO OTHER RELIEF PROGRAMS SUCH
AS THE FEDERAL SHUTTERED VENUE
OPERATORS GRANT. MUSEUMS THAT
DO NOT HAVE AN ATTITUDE
AUDITORIUM OR THEATER WITH
EXCEEDING ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS GRANT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING CLOSELY WITH YOU OTHER
LEGISLATORS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CRAFT AN
EFFECTIVE RELIEF PROGRAM. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
I'LL FOLLOW ON TO LAST I'M
MICHAEL KEVIN DIRECTOR OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY MUSEUM OF.
ART AND I'M AND I'M SURE THANK
YOU FOR THIS EVENT- WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE TRAGIC IMPACT OF THIS
CLOSURE ON ON US ECONOMICALLY
ARTISTICALLY ON THE HEALTH OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. LARGE LAST
MONTH THE LARGEST ART MUSEUM IN
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES ITS
BEEN CLOSED FOR TEN MONTHS. I'D
LIKE TO FOCUS ON THE POSITIVE.
AND FOLLOWING ON FROM LAST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
ENCOURAGE ART MUSEUMS ENCOURAGE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO OPEN US
NOW EVEN IN HERE. BECAUSE WE
ALREADY HAVE THE GUIDELINES TO
REOPEN IN FACT WE HELPED
DEVELOP THOSE GUIDELINES FOR
ART MUSEUMS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
USE SINCE JUNE AND THAT'S THE
LAST SAID SINCE OCTOBER AS OF
OCTOBER OVER TWO MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE SAFELY VISITED ART
MUSEUMS- WE'RE READY TO GO WE
CAN GIVE YOU THE PROTOCOLS. AND
L. A. ACTUALLY IS THE WAS THE
ONLY MAJOR METROPOLITAN AREA TO
NEVER RE OPEN. WHAT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE THAT
IS FOR CALIFORNIA. AND FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR ARTISTS FOR
JOBS- IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE
CAN REOPEN IMPACT I WOULD SAY
THAT YOU COULDN'T FIND A SAFER
INDOOR SPACE AND ART MUSEUM IN
CALIFORNIA SAFETIES BUILT IN
AND IT'S BEEN ENHANCED WE HAVE
MONITORED CONTROLLED
ENVIRONMENTS THANKS TO OUR
SECURITY AND VISITOR SERVICES-
TEAM THEY CAN ENCOURAGE AND
ENFORCE. MASK WEARING AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING WHERE
NATURALLY TOUCHLESS WHO HASN'T
BEEN IN FOR THE MUSEUM AND BEEN
TOLD NOT TO TOUCH IN OTHER
TIMES WE HAVE WIDE OPEN SPACES
WIDE OPEN SPACES UNLIKE A LOT
OF RETAIL WE HAVE MASSIVE AIR
FILTRATION SYSTEMS WE HAVE A
THOROUGH CLEANING ANYWAY AND
THAT'S BEEN ENHANCED FURTHER-
WE HAVE ONLINE TICKETING. AND
WE CAN ADJUST OUR AUDIENCES HE
WANTED 25% ONE OF THE 10% BACK
UP TO FORTY WE CAN DO IT AND WE
DO IT WITH- ONE TO ONE
COMMUNICATION WITH THEIR
AUDIENCE YOU HAVE TO FILL OUT A
QUESTIONNAIRE WHERE WE CAN HAVE
A HEALTH SCREEN. PROMOTE
PROTOCOLS WE CAN. CREATE
CONTACT TRACING THROUGH THAT WE
HAVE TEMPERATURE CHECKS WHEN
YOU GET THERE WHEN YOU GET
THERE THE CALORIES ARE ONE WAY
TRAFFIC WITH MARKS ON THE
FLOOR. AND MOST RETAIL DOESN'T
COME CLOSE TO THE LEVEL OF
SAFETY THAT WE HAVE TO OFFER WE
ARE READY AND WILLING TO SHARE
THESE GUIDELINES WE HAVE
ALREADY WITH THE REST OF THE
NATION IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
READY TO RESTART THE ARTS THE
ECONOMY JOBS TO CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES. TO HELP PEOPLE
RECOVER FROM STRESS TO LEARN TO
BE INSPIRED AND WE NEED TO DO
IT NOW SAFELY IT IS REALLY
PAINFUL. TO BE A PUBLIC SERVICE
LIKE OURS. AND CLOSED WHEN WE
NOW WE CAN BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND THIS NEW DATA OF
ALL OF THESE OTHER CITIES
MUSEUMS BEING OPEN. SHOWS THAT
IT IS SAFE TO BE IN MUSEUMS AND
WE SHULD USE MUSEUMS TO HELP.
EMPOWER CALIFORNIA THE ARTS THE
ECONOMY. AND ALL OF US. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THOSE MOMENTS- WE
REALLY HAVE HEARD QUITE A BIT
TODAY AND EVERY ONE OF YOUR
TESTIMONIES NOT REALLY ADDS TO
THE RECORD. ADDS TO THE URGENCY
OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO AS A
STATE AND WE ARE AGAIN A ROAD
DOWN IF YOU WANT TO SAY THIS A
RIVER TOGETHER. AND AS WE DO
THAT I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO END
THIS SO IF YOU DO HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS WERE GOING TO ASK YOU-
OKAY WE ARE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
SUBMIT THOSE TO- TO THE RECORD
AND WE DO HAVE OUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ADRIN NAZARIAN THAT
DOES HAVE SOME FINAL COMMENTS
AND HAS BEEN LISTENING
INTENTIONALLY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AGAIN I
HAD TO STEP BACK IN- TO ASK A
QUESTION TO THE CEO OF- OF- LA
COUNTY MUSEUM OF ART THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY. JUST
WANTED TO KNOW FROM YOUR
EXPERIENCE MICHAEL- WHAT WHAT
CONVERSATIONS HAVE YOU HAD WITH
THE COUNTY. OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
FIND IT ASTONISHINGLY
INTERESTING THAT THE MALLS JUST
DOWN THE STREET FROM ME ARE
OPEN WHICH IS GOOD IT'S
IMPORTANT. BUT THAT MUSEUMS
ESPECIALLY MUSEUMS OF THE LARGE
SCALE THAT- HAVE MUCH HOPE IN
SPACES AND CAN BE MANAGED. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE INFLOW OF
INDIVIDUALS DOESN'T REACH
CAPACITIES THAT WILL BE
DETRIMENTAL TO ANYONE'S HEALTH
TO GIVEN ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
MUSEUMS. BECOME A SOURCE OF
REFUGE I MEAN AT A TIME LIKE
THIS WITH THREE YOUNG KIDS
ESPECIALLY WE'VE BECAUSE THEY
LOOK TO SEE WHERE WE CAN GO
WANT TO KNOW WHAT SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN AND
WHERE THE CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN
AND- AGAIN HOW CAN WE HELP AND-
SPECIFICALLY FOR LA AREA HOW
CAN THE ALLEY DELEGATION ALSO
STEP IN AND HELP. BUT THEN
MAYBE HELP ALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AS WELL WITH ALL OF OUR
CALLERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
YEAH YES ACTUALLY WHEN
DEVELOPED PROTOCOLS THAT ARE
BEING USED NATION WHY. THEY
WERE DEVELOPED WITH LOS ANGELES
CITY AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND THIRD PARTY CONSULTANTS
BOSTON CONSULTING GROUP. WE
WERE READY TO RE OPENING IN
JULY AND- WE SHARED OUR
PARTICLES WITH EVERYONE. L. A.
COUNTY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH DR FERRER IN LA IN
FACT SHE- LOVES MUSEUMS AS
TOUCHLESS ENVIRONMENTS- BUT
IT'S CALIFORNIA- THAT QUICK
MUSEUMS IN THE LOWER. CATEGORY
IN AS A JUNIOR L. L. A. BE- IT
HAS TO BE MORE RESTRICTIVE NOT
LESS RESTRICTIVE THAN
CALIFORNIA. SO I DO BELIEVE I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THOSE OF
FLORIDIANS BUT GIVEN WE WORK SO
CLOSELY WITH THEM. I THINK IF
CALIFORNIA WERE TO SPEAK WITH
THEM THEY WOULD REALIZE THAT
THEY IS THAT LA HAD PRIORITIZED
THE ARTS BECAUSE WE ARE SAFE
AND WE CAN BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO. THE FACT THAT WE
CAN KEEP PEOPLE FROM TRAVELING
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT TO DO IT
ALL. SO WE'RE READY IT GETS
CALIFORNIA AND NOW I NEED TO
COMMUNICATE- BETTER AND I THINK
CALIFORNIA- CAN BE CATEGORIZED
MUSEUMS TO THEIR PROPER. STATUS
AND THEN WE. CAN REOPEN EXCEPT.
I YOU FOR THE CALL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND FOR YOUR ANSWERED
THAT REALLY. DOES HIT AT THE
HEART OF WHERE SOME OF THIS. IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHY CAN WE HAVE SOME
PEOPLE. FOR MANY PEOPLE. YEAH
GOING INTO MALLS. OR LARGE
RETAIL AND IT WAS IT APPEARS TO
BE YOU KNOW- NO MAN MASK
MANDATE I KNOW TEMPERATURE
TAKING WHERE AS WE KNOW LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE DISNEY IS TAKING
TEMPERATURES EVEN TO ENTER
DOWNTOWN DISNEY HANDWASHING
STATIONS. ALL TYPES OF CAST
MEMBERS- AVAILABLE TO ENCOURAGE
EVEN IF A MASK SLIPS DOWN- SO
THIS IS THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION AND I DO THINK IT'S
GOT TO BE ANSWERED- I AIRED WE
DO HAVE A PUBLIC SPEAKER UP IN
OUR CHAMBERS- AND WE'RE LOOKING
WAY UP AT THE TOP OF THE
GALLERY WELCOME. HELLO MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TOWARD WAS READY
THREE SAY ON BEHALF OF THE
VENUES CO READ VENUES HERE IN
SAC- ALSO UNTIL. WITH
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED VENUES FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- MADAM
CHAIR YOU ASKED- TO PUT
INVESTMENT IN THE ARTS ECONOMY
NAMELY THE AND LIVE INDEPENDENT
MUSIC VENUES- IS AN INVESTMENT
IN CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- AS MY COLLEAGUES FROM
ANOTHER PLANET MENTIONED-
MARYLAND FOR EXAMPLE ALLOCATED
THIRTY MILLION FOR. THEIR
INDEPENDENT LIVE MUSIC VENUES.
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA THESE ARE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS THESE ARE
THERE THE ECONOMIC IMPACT IS
BROAD AND FAR REACHING- I
WOULD- APPRECIATE THE
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION
AND THE HEARING TODAY I THINK
THIS IS CRITICAL REOPENING IS A
KEY PART OF THIS EQUATION BUT
THE OTHER HALF IS WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THOSE
VENUES FROM SHUTTERING IN THE
MEANTIME SO- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH. YOURSELF MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIR- YOUR
STAFF AS WELL AS THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THAT LIFE PLAN LOOKS LIKE-
AND WE APPRECIATE AGAIN YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE IN YOUR ATTENTION TO
FIGURING OUT HOW WE SAVE OUR
STAGES HERE IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN TO THOSE ONLINE LISTENING
TO US TO EVERY ONE OF OUR
PANELISTS WE SINCERELY THANK
YOU. ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS YOUR
DATA YOUR INFORMATION YOUR
SLIDES WILL GO ON RECORD AND WE
CERTAINLY HAVE BUILT A VERY.
ROBUST- IF YOU WANT TO.
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY HERE THAT
WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE
<c.cyan>OVERNOR'S OFFICE FROM OUR</c>
OFFICE. I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT- WE ARE ALSO WORKING ON A
TOURISM. BILL THAT WOULD BE
WORKING WITH SENATOR MCGUIRE.
RELATED TO AN INVESTMENT FOR
TOURISM AND MARKETING THROUGH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I'M A
JOINT AUTHOR ON THAT. MY VICE
CHAIR HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SUZETTE MARTINEZ ALL THERE IS A
NIGHT OR- WILL BE INTRODUCING A
THEME PARK BILL TO RE LOOK AT
THE TEARS. THAT THEME PARKS ARE
AND AGAIN KNOWING. THAT IT'S
NOT JUST THE GUIDELINES BUT
IT'S ALSO. THE TEARS THAT SOME
OF THESE. PARTNERS ARE IN THAT
MAKE IT VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO
PLAN FOR. ANY TYPE OF FUTURE
HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE WANT. NOT
ONLY. OUR ECONOMY TO BOUNCE
BACK BUT WE WANT THOUSANDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. IN
CALIFORNIA TO START TO HAVE
HOPE FOR OUR GREAT STATE AGAIN.
WITH THAT THANK YOU EVERYBODY
WHO PUT THIS. COMMITTEE
TOGETHER THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING AND. TO BE SAFE THANK
YOU.